there's no time o clock hey y'all
episode 186 of the 13 o'clock podcast
that's right Ed Gein
we're finally getting around to talking
about Ed Gein is so excited about I know
that's is that messed up that's messed
up
um but well you know it's we didn't do
like a lot of the kind of big-ticket we
were talking about this before when we
were doing like Gacy and stuff we didn't
do like a lot of the kind of big-ticket
serial killers when we first started out
because we were kind of trying to I
guess fill gaps in the market or like
you know we were trying to compete you
know talk about ones that work maybe is
well-known or have as many videos about
this back in the early days the best way
to get subscribers was to talk about
stuff that was kind of rare and obscure
and trying to hook up with people that
were looking for that yeah yeah and I
mean some of the cases that no one else
is doing so that's you that's how we got
our foot in the door anyway yeah so now
it's time where you know we haven't we
have a big enough subscriber base where
we can talk about this yeah yeah I mean
and I I really I've been wanting to do
Ed Gein for a long time because even
though he's not technically a serial
killer that they know of and that he
didn't kill enough people to be a serial
killer and his motivation wasn't really
the same I feel like he became way more
of a cultural icon that's not too weird
to say then you know a lot of other
serial killers just because I mean he's
the only murderer or criminal of this
type that I know of that has inspired
three iconic horror characters this you
know woman babes from psycho Leatherface
from Texas Chainsaw Massacre and Buffalo
Bill from Silence of the land's all
three of whom were based loosely on Ed
Gein if he wasn't technically a serial
killer and there's some
question two that he may have actually
been he might have killed some more
people then yeah they I don't know but
if he wasn't a serial killer
technically by the book he was gonna be
had he not been caught yeah eventually
he would have killed three yeah probably
well I I mean we'll get into that a
little bit later but I think he did yeah
you know three at least but he only
really confessed to two and they really
only convicted him of one but I don't
know there there is some question there
but like I said the the weird thing
about Ed Gein is that his motivation he
wasn't like a Ted Bundy type or
something like that were like they're a
sexual sadist he was more like worried
about he was more like a a necrophiliac
type of you know they don't really know
if he had sex with the dead bodies he
said that he didn't but you some like he
had some kind of like fetishistic thing
for like dead bodies or women's skin or
things made out of women after they were
dead but I don't think he got any
particular enjoyment out of murdering
the women he didn't like torture them or
anything like I think this is one of
those cases where the case you know I
mean his case Falls in a gray area and
the gray area is really defined by FBI
criteria yeah but that's just the case
the reality of who he was I don't think
falls in the gray area I think he was a
serial killer yeah you know he just was
either in the making or they didn't we
don't know everything about it
I also it's like I said no proof that he
was a necrophile yeah but now that
[ __ ] was an actor it would be
strange if he wasn't right just because
he had like such a fetishes like like
vacation there was a sexual element
there no deafness was part of his sexual
identity you know we can't prove it but
we know the way serial killers are and
this is one of them one thing about him
that I feel like he wasn't as I said he
wasn't kind of your textbooks textbook
serial killer in the sense of he didn't
suffer from he wasn't like a sociopath
or a psychopath
he was more like a psychotic I think he
definitely had like some schizophrenia
issues I think he definitely had some
mental issues and he did actually end up
going to a mental asylum instead of
prison a couple things about the case
though that make you wonder I mean first
of all not a real modern case yeah this
was a long time ago
the investigative techniques for those
days could work probably weren't gonna
to pry the truth out of him and we're
not dealing with a modern person even
though he was caught the 50s
his upbringing in the way he was was
kind of something alien from another
time zone he was real rural he was
almost something that could have been
from the 1800s so a normal modern
psychology I don't think it's quite the
same yeah and he grew up really in
isolation to like as his family
situation yeah if you really analyze it
the 1800s wasn't too different from the
sixteen hundreds and that's not too
different from [ __ ] 200 BC you know I
mean so the Roman period was a lot well
it's really only since like the
Industrial Revolution that everything
kind of like exponentially like chained
right so he's it's difficult to judge
the guy by modern standards because I
don't he was modern yeah I guess not
yeah but we'll talk about the kid but
he's still like a fascinating case and
like I said not only has he been you
know the inspiration for three iconic
horror big villains but he's still like
even nowadays you can go to [ __ ]
there's like Etsy stores that are like
devoted to making like lampshades and
vests and stuff like that that look like
they're made of human skin hopefully
they're not really made of human skin
but it's like that are inspired by him
right which is messed up but I don't
know we were talking about this like
when we were out for a walk earlier and
I was I said that I was listening to
because I watched like a bunch of
documentaries and I read all this stuff
oh my my bread his murder pedia with you
no entry and everything and the last
podcast on the left had done like a
three-part series about him and I
thought it was very funny because I do I
don't listen to them regularly but I do
like like them when I listen to
and the funny thing is that every now
and then we will get like some YouTube
comment about how we're making like
jokes about like these really horrific
topics and everything like that I'm like
have you ever listened to that show holy
crap it's like they made some [ __ ] and I
admit that I laughed cuz I have like a
really [ __ ] up messed-up sense of
humor
obviously nobody thinks it's good like
these poor women that he killed or these
poor bodies that he'd the families of
these women whose bodies he desecrated
but it's like it in a way you almost
kind of have to laugh because it's so
[ __ ] horrifying that you don't really
know what else to do yeah what I'm a way
I look at it like this first of all you
don't want to
we're horrified by this [ __ ] yeah of
course
everybody normal person would be
everybody is in this particular case the
relatives of all the victims are either
old very old and they're they're dead
okay in in no way we mocking the crimes
you know or what happened to these
victims all right in a way
we're mocking the [ __ ] perpetrator
yeah all right these dudes want to be
feared a lot of times they want to be
seen as something fun kind of superhuman
or godlike that they're above all no
they're [ __ ] losers alright the best
thing to do about these dudes is just to
make fun of them yeah they got problems
they're trying to be something that
they're not you know just because they
kill people doesn't mean anything that
doesn't mean you think doesn't mean
they're more than anybody else the kind
of people they're killing and the
motives that they're using mixing less
than other people know these are scum
and the thing is I got I don't think
because I was listening to something
about this earlier and I think that
there is maybe maybe it's not that
widespread but there is kind of a
perception that people who are really
fascinated by serial killers are
fascinated by true crime in general that
there's something wrong with them or but
I don't think that's what it is because
it's like I like you said I am horrified
by these types of crimes you know it
freaks me out it's like I think about it
a lot you know I feel really bad for the
victims for their families like what
they had to go through and everything
but in another way humor and horror
our very side-by-side you know what I
mean and it's kind of like you know
joking about this kind of stuff is like
a defense mechanism just because you
can't really [ __ ] deal with because
it's so odd it's like so unusual it's so
out of most people's experience
I should note too that even though
people like you know would maybe think
that you know some of the jokes they
made on last podcast and laughed about
this case were tasteless or something
but I should note that even at the time
that Ed Gein's crimes were discovered
back in the 40s and 50s people made sick
jokes about it there were so many that
they were called gainers there was a
whole subculture of sick jokes about Ed
Gein what's Ed Gein's favorite dessert
ladyfingers it's like there was like a
whole [ __ ] genre yeah the [ __ ] up
joke it's just like dead baby jokes
right it's like no one wicked that tells
those wants to kill babies it's just you
know no in a case like this the best
thing to do is [ __ ] laugh at it if
you ask me first of all recognize it for
for what it is you're dealing with a
[ __ ] subhuman person really who's
doing bad things to dead bodies and
killing psychology has gone there
drastically when they're [ __ ] up all
right you can't fix it and you can't
reverse it one thing you can do is
apprehend that person to stop them and
punish them or do whatever it is you
need to do to make sure that it doesn't
happen again
and that justice is served and after
that fact if you ask me the best thing
to do is is to kind of ridicule it yeah
I guess is the last thing that they want
yeah they do not want they do not want
to be ridiculed none of them do yeah
even our boy here well that's basically
why I said here's actual problems in his
weekly bang on and Dennis the last thing
Dennis would ever want was to be
ridiculed right which is why I do it
it's a ridicule of other [ __ ] that's
the best way now Ed Gein is he's also an
unusual case because he's one of those
maybe Dahmer's like this too we still
have to do a show about Dahmer one of
these days maybe we'll do one in the
next few months he was from Wisconsin -
what the hell's going on Scott said
anybody lives in Wisconsin tell me
what's going on well
northeast rural area I guess there's
nothing better to do let's act in the
day it was a very small window getting
suit but yet so I wonder Ed Gein is one
of those people that I wonder had he
grown up in a normal family would he
have been alright you know I think he
might have been yeah oh yeah well I
think he might have been he had some
mental problems but I think that if he
had grown up in a loving house because
his family situation was [ __ ] up he
didn't have like varied experiences that
- he was very isolated and yeah so I
wonder Overton Window of acceptability
was very small and that drove him
[ __ ] crazy and caused him to do this
yeah I definitely feel like and maybe
Dumber to like to a lesser extent but I
definitely I definitely feel like in ed
Gein's case you know yes he probably had
some mental problems yes maybe he had a
proclivity you know toward that like
from birth or whatever but I do think if
he had been raised in like a loving
household a normal household if he'd
been allowed to have friends have
relationships had a normal relationship
with his parents I think he might have
turned out okay yeah it doesn't matter
what country you come from what race you
are what your culture is these
[ __ ] are weird all these guys
that commit these kind of crimes are not
normal by any standards you know what I
mean
thankfully this [ __ ] ain't normal
alright so especially this case yeah
it's not normal this is I don't even
like I don't usually feel cuz you know
you guys know most of the people that
listen to our show like our regular
listeners you know we talked about some
folks we talked about fucked-up [ __ ]
like all the time so it's like I I never
really feel the need to be like hey if
you're like easily grossed out or
anything like that maybe you don't want
to listen this case I'm not sure cuz
there's some pretty [ __ ] going on in
this these dudes are created it's a
perfect storm of a bunch of different
problems happening at once it they're
very improbable that's what makes them
rare well that's what makes them
fascinating also because most people
thankfully can't imagine ya doing
anything like this
might be a combination of damn eight or
nine [ __ ] weird-ass things all
happening at once yeah
but it but you know what every one of us
has might have one or two of these
things oh yeah
be inside you it's just that when you
got eight of them working together it's
like a perfect storm and the next thing
you know you got these [ __ ] yeah you
know and it needs to be studied that's
what this show is all about that's what
[ __ ] forensic Criminology and
criminal psychology is all about that
trying to figure out that's what I mean
where'd these guys come from and what
makes them tick you know and how can we
like prevent people from going that
right and here at 13 o'clock the only
thing we can do is to tell you what the
[ __ ] happened there were yeah we're
gonna [ __ ] make fun of it
yeah or [ __ ] explore it and you guys
think it along for the ride you guys
like this kind of [ __ ] everybody likes
this kind of [ __ ] it's kind of like a
real life at least I inform people it's
a nonfiction horror movie it is that's
what that's what I'm like I said it's
like I've always been ever since [ __ ]
I can remember ever since I was a child
I've been fascinated with anything
horrific or morbid or anything like that
and it's like I didn't get it as much
for my parents because my parents were
pretty chill but it's like I did get it
from you know some of my teachers in
school thought I was a little weird and
it's like she shouldn't be reading it
just weird as crazy well I know I am
kind of but um not a bad way she's not I
would never hurt anyone she's actually
not weird that's what I mean I don't
think I'm weird if other people do I
don't think I'm weird at all I think I'm
one of the most normal people I [ __ ]
know I have a lot of people that are way
weird but it's like I you know the fact
that people think that it's weird that
you're into horror weird that you're in
the true-crime I think a lot of people
are into it or fascinated by it but are
afraid of their fascination what I found
it strange about it is that it's mostly
women that are into this oh yeah women
love [ __ ] guys don't like it too much
and I'm this just me talking to other
guys in the show okay guys don't really
like this that much we get mad which is
I think it's a normal male real I get
mad do get very mad and it's get mad to
a normal man
male reacted normal males reaction is to
get mad because we have protective
instincts yeah especially towards women
and children a lot of this [ __ ] has
happened and the women and children we
get mad you know you won't want to kill
this [ __ ]
no and that's just I teach you I don't
wanna if I read about it there is
something kind of where like you know I
want to find out what this dude did and
what happened but you as you're reading
you're kind of like man put this [ __ ]
down you're gonna get mad yeah I mean
maybe that's why he didn't let me like
watch true crime stuff I can watch one
of them because seriously when he like
he was gone for two weeks like visiting
his dad or something like I think I I I
just sat there and watch like cold-case
files just like just like something like
all the true crime shows on Netflix
because I can watch one of them but if I
watch started watching more than one of
the cases I started getting mad and and
it's not it hurt but I started getting
mad at the TV at the TV and you get mad
at the circumstances because I feel
helpless and I know there's gonna be a
lot of guys that are you know in the
audience they're gonna understand
exactly like I want to stop it but I
can't do anything because it's on
television and it's something that
already did already happened and you
can't so you I give that like I feel
like that too in association
particularly some of the kids because I
write about them so I haven't kind of
like immersed in it like all the time
so I read about stuff and it does it
makes me really angry like sometimes
I'll read about a case and I start I'll
bust out crying like for like if
something like really horrific like
happened to the person or something it
really like upsets me but on the other
hand it's like I'm able to temper that
with my Spock like instincts being like
what is wrong with this person that did
this what is their pathology can we
prevent this from happening again so I
really kind of get interested in why
that person did the like what the [ __ ]
is the matter with that person that made
them do that what was the circumstance
that made that happen
so yes I get upset yes I get emotional
about it but I'm kind of abled I come at
it from like a balanced kind of thing I
guess where I'm able to I'm not saying
that I'm like distancing myself from it
because I don't
but I'm able to look at it from like an
emotional side and also like a logical
side like what is the matter with this
person and what how can we recognize
like another person that would do
something like that you know what I mean
so I kind of feel like that's why so
that kind of [ __ ] fascinates me I don't
I could watch true crime in horror
movies all the time and just never watch
anything else I seriously could I know
that's I can't take it
yeah I can you know meet I'm ex-military
MX infantry you know I mean I can watch
like an infantry stories about grown men
and warfare killing each other all day
long and I'm [ __ ] I'm right there I
understand it yeah I mean as soon as you
start talking about killing innocent
women and children for sexual reasons or
just whatever now I go [ __ ] precise
but see I don't understand it that's why
I want to watch it because I want to
know why why it's not just me because
you know I got patrons to subscribers
that [ __ ] say your guys were good man
Ross I know exactly you're talking about
a feel exact same [ __ ] way I would
kill that [ __ ] I'd put that dude
in I would even bull and because I'm
about ancient Greece always weird
tortures and stuff am I getting
bloodthirsty when I started 92 some of
these dudes I need em so like man what I
would do to that dude oh yeah if I had
got my hands on some of these oh yeah
right oh yeah so it's not just the same
I'm just saying I think that too but I
feel helpless that I can't stop it cuz
yeah happened in the past and I wasn't
there you know so I don't want you know
what I mean it's just I I you seem to
[ __ ] get off on it like it's in there
it like it's it's entertainment but not
really I know you know it's it's about
yeah it's not entertaining exactly for
it is interesting and me I see it more
like additional training yeah that I'm
being instructed okay that these guys
exist and that I have to keep my eye out
for them maybe yeah that's the way I'm
coming out of - okay all right that's
the normal male responses - [ __ ] I don't
find it entertaining
okay let's you know now I want to
understand the enemy yeah that's that's
kind of word that's what I'm doing -
yeah so you know I got out I had just a
couple okay
so uh let's see who are we shouting out
this week oh we are shouting out our
friend Melanie who has given us a PayPal
donation as she often does we appreciate
every single one of them yeah we'll be
sitting here all sudden get your big
paycheck to Chang we're like man thank
you we didn't expect it
I know it's always so it's so nice when
like I not all get like a movie at the
mail or something it's like it's like
getting slick Christmas what some people
don't want to do patreon and I
understand that patreon get some of that
money patreon [ __ ] sometimes flex
people over and sometimes it's better
just [ __ ] although I haven't had any bad
experiences as a patron but me you know
maybe other people have I have I have
not
you know they've they've been a delight
so far they've been good to us yeah um I
would also like to thank Mary Ellen who
was already our patreon patron but also
she increased her support yeah this past
week so thank you very very awesome a
thank you very much because I don't
really you don't remember right I wrote
it down like a long time ago but then I
forgot to put it in my notes put in my
notes for the show so yeah thank you
very much you guys the show continues
because of patrons like you guys yes
definitely I got a small crew of
dedicated patrons that [ __ ] pay us a
lot of money and also everybody that
like kind of comments and the thing I
say I can't like I don't have like a lot
of time because sometimes I want to like
go back in and like kind of do you know
more in depth you know answers to
people's comments and stuff and I you
know sometimes I don't have time to get
around to it but I am like reading all
of them yeah and so what I have to have
we broken 600 yet not yeah we're almost
where I think we're at 560 you bring
something like that we're trying to
break $1,000 a month if you guys could
help us at one night much appreciation I
feel like if because remember when we
said when we broke $1,000 a month that
we would do another show now see I
already started doing witching hour just
because I felt like doing that and I was
already reading [ __ ] anyway um but I do
feel like I had like one or two people
ask me because remember a long time ago
we were talking about doing like a retro
show yeah
and people are like hey like are you
guys ever gonna do that I'm like maybe
well maybe we'll do
playful me get c1000 cuz I still do kind
of want to do that guys good understand
not only did Jenny do the show she runs
her graphic design through here we do
screen printing and I write books tales
yeah and I design board game she's
writing books and written board games
and a new book is I've like five jobs
she works a lot gig economy so yeah no
weekend's no vacations don't know yeah
the YouTube show isn't the main thing we
kind of do this mostly for an
advertisement to help sell books well we
cut and we do it kind of for fun move on
to yeah as well yeah this is our social
life it is now yeah I need to start
going back out to the clubs but yeah no
[ __ ] I'm free I'm just giddy afraid he's
gonna get coronavirus I just got over
Corona you did not have I just had kovin
it's awesome everything like I have
never been afraid of a flu in my whole
entire life and I am not about to start
now
salut isn't gonna [ __ ] kill me I'm a
survivor
okay I'm gonna survive the [ __ ]
apocalypse when it comes you know talk
about I'm like I'm gonna be killed by
little animals little kovin viruses
that's like the equivalent of B that's
what I'm sayin like no please not gonna
[ __ ] kill me that's like equivalent
being eaten by bugs I'm not going down
like that okay I'm not going [ __ ] down
like that's what I mean I really don't
want to die like that come out that's so
lame well that's what I mean it's in a
way it's like yeah I can see why people
are flipping out about it but just like
I said on the pandemic show I'm not like
belittling people that is like you know
I know some people have died from it and
[ __ ] like that black people dies but the
thing is it's a flu it's not as bad as
Spanish flu it's not even as bad as the
Zika virus from 2009
so flus are bad I mean people do die
from the flu every year and I feel like
people don't talk about that but they do
well I'll tell you this you're gonna say
it's just a flu but it's it's tarin
[ __ ] Iran up right now yeah that's a
flu but it's killing people and
but like I said all flus kill people but
this thing's killing people it seems
somewhere between 3 and 3 and 6%
fatalities there at 1.6 between 1.6 and
2.4 that's what I heard it depends on
who you're talking to
that was from CDC I don't trust
everything that they say okay their
stock market okay we'll know when it
starts going into [ __ ] countries that
tell the truth it's in countries that
don't tell the truth right now well know
when it gets the air up okay if it
starts working them [ __ ] white boys
over real hard we're gonna know about it
okay yeah although like I said I'm just
I'm not gonna worry about it I can't I'm
not worried about it yeah you are
I'm not well I have my own defense
mechanisms talked about I didn't see my
immune system I'm [ __ ] he's been
you've been sick it's not it's not
correct he keeps telling me I have Cove
it I'm like no you don't knock it off
that's my story yeah what we're talking
about though the matinee show a little
about everything I do is say is a
hundred percent serious okay well I hope
everybody would realize that right now
okay sir pretty much like 84 so what he
says no I'm notional that's the ghost
that's a good way of putting yes
notional national you like that yeah
okay that's a good word because it's
there's no judgment involved I was gonna
say [ __ ] II know but it's notional
is better yeah it's more diplomatic yeah
well I'm just trying to experience life
you're talking about it and to
experience life you have to think that
you have the coronavirus when you don't
know I well I knew it wasn't corona but
maybe kinda like you're trying to like
make it more exciting it was it was it
was Corona then that means that I I
whipped its ass okay I can't I'm about
yeah which makes me has she been sick
like a week or two at least and he just
he's mystified that I haven't got it
yeah if it was Kona if it was good she
would've got it I'm like I hardly ever
get to play oh I don't hardly I hardly
ever get colds I hardly ever get
anything yeah well I've been like that
my whole life you know what I mean
I don't get a lot
of businesses whatever even when I was
little you know what you know when you
were little and you were getting like
chickenpox and stuff like my siblings
had it like really bad I got it for like
a day or two and had like three spots
and then it went away well I'm just
saying I have like super immune system
it's in it's in my nature to look for
danger and to plan for it and to
overcome that's a part of life you know
the mint shitty understands it I mean I
didn't I was raised in a military
academy I've been all the [ __ ] world
in the Army for the did weird kind of
law enforcement work for what law
enforcement units and any terrorist type
units and [ __ ] I did weird [ __ ] my
whole [ __ ] life
the other man so it's it's my it's it's
in my nature to try to spot [ __ ] and to
plan for it but not you know not little
stuff big stuff I like big stuff yeah he
likes like world ending yeah yeah a lot
you like some thinking about roldan yeah
I like big stuff I like to negotiate
[ __ ] big problems I like that I'm
just kind of like very live on that and
she Lance I [ __ ] thrive on that [ __ ]
he does yeah you know I'm so like wow
that is not in the show cuz there's much
of private stuff that it's not in the
show she knows though yeah I thrive on
that [ __ ] yeah
you know but that's good that's just the
world and I'm not the only one there's
some of you people out there in the
audience and know exactly what I'm
talking about and the world needs people
like us because we like to overcome
things we shall overcome yeah I like to
overcome taste
yeah I'm looking I'm kind of more I'm
very like I'm a very pragmatic person
and I'm just so I'm just kind of like
okay um I just need like enough money at
the end of the month to pay my bills so
that's kind of my main concern yeah you
know what I mean if it like a committee
if yeah it's like move it intervenes I
will deal with it when is it I'm not
gonna worry about [ __ ] that I think is
probably that is unlikely to James act
mayor affect my situation Jenny and I
are like a committee we are you okay I
handle one
some [ __ ] she handles some other [ __ ]
and we've got it all covered
we try to yeah like I said we kind of
like fill each other's gaps in because
we're like so different so yeah so did I
have any other shoutouts probably not
yeah go check out our Instagram if I
didn't say it last time because I just
started that [ __ ] and like I said I
started doing like the weekly Dennis
Rader sexual problems Adam seemed from
conspiratorial said please make this a
weekly thing and I'm like oh I plan on
it yeah I just quote well because I have
that book that Sophie sent me about the
BTK and it's got like all kind of like
really fun quotes in there like of all
the stupid [ __ ] that he said yes so
every so every week I just like put a
new if you guys don't know Adam man
check out Adam he's got a good show I
like doing a show we've done a show like
a whole pair normal yeah several times
and I've been on a few times by myself
and we've been on it a couple times I've
been on a lot of the [ __ ] bonus
material on patreon yeah this patreon
and he'll be like super hot super drunk
and he'll just like go on these long
rants I'm not even talking I'm just like
over there staring fitness they love it
so they love that [ __ ] though because I
will they ask me the [ __ ] tough
questions and that's enough questions
and tough questions and I answer them
and I'm [ __ ] I'm real honest you know
I mean I'm real honest to general it's
just that there's certain things that we
there are certain things that we don't
talk about on the mainstream show
although not much is there there isn't
much but we're like open books yeah
that's about the mainstream shows that
we don't delve into things that are too
politically [ __ ] polarizing yeah
because the show was supposed to be a
always a show for everybody but Jenny
and I both have political ideas and
ideas that involve politics in the Army
all those people do yeah everyone who
has like the right and left [ __ ]
dichotomy they're gonna have a different
take on things and you know they'll ask
me a question and I'll [ __ ] tell them
ya know what I think I think just people
are people and I think people tend be
full of [ __ ]
but there are certain things that
survive contact with reality and other
things that don't and I think by virtue
of my personal experiences with [ __ ]
reality and [ __ ] military and law
enforcement type stuff a lot of people
believe in some [ __ ] yeah well I
would agree a lot of people believe in
some [ __ ] but and there's a lot of
[ __ ] in the mainstream well there's
kind of a lot of [ __ ] everywhere but
well like I said that's a very human
thing human brains are really not
constructed to be very good at logical
thinking I've noticed humans have a foot
humans have a propensity towards
idealistic thinking do you think I don't
know I don't know that's true I don't
know if that's true in religion or
politics I think it's more magical
thinking I don't think it's idealist
okay well I think idealism is also the
form of magical thinking to reality is a
lot more mundane a reality is very
mundane most of the time well that's why
I don't get too like excited about
anything because most stuff isn't as
cool and now or is or is apocalyptic as
it seems like yeah they're trying to get
me all like excite but it's not all no
I'm just lying this guy it's not pie in
the sky well I don't think that either
and promises never really come to
fruition especially when you're talking
about [ __ ] big-ass systems listen I
talked about this you want to talk about
a game let's go ahead and talk about a
game let's throw the Finn start the
episode okay we did talk about him a
little bit at first so that's good so
any so anybody that's like wanted to
whine about it is like you know what I
mean at least we talked about yeah at
the beginning yeah you can always go on
[ __ ] if you want to know about a game
you can always just go on damn [ __ ]
Wikipedia Reading Is Fundamental Reading
Is Fundamental but this is a show and
you're probably working or you guys
phones on you get trying to go to sleep
and and and where we're recording this I
know it's Tuesday when you guys are
listening more Monday for a patron
Friday but we're we're recording this on
Friday evening yeah so we decided we'll
do them on Friday night or Saturday
night just so we can justify like
drinking here in the show and not
feeling better even though we sometimes
do that we'd be at the club if you know
we weren't doing this trail so we'd be
drinking anyway yeah that is yeah I mean
Friday and Saturday nights are like
drinkin yeah that's just how we do makes
the show better usually yeah all right
so let's talk about Ed Gein yeah now
Edward Theodore gain which last podcast
on left I didn't think of this but they
pointed out there like so his name is
Eddy teddy yeah Edward Theodore yeah
that was a nice come on yes so he was
born in 1906 now he was born in La
Crosse Wisconsin
his parents were George Jean and Augusta
Gein now George the dad was and this
happens with a lot of serial killers was
a drunk was also sources differ some
said that he was kind of abusive or or
at least he was not he was kind of a bum
really like he didn't really have that
much of a job he didn't have really had
that much money or anything um you know
so he was kind of like a [ __ ] of
failure whatever now
Augusta the mother she was quite a
different story
this is she's kind of like you know the
Stephen King book Carrie okay kind of
like her mom Wow that that's kind of
what Augusta was like she was this big
burly um woman with you know she was
like a baby like square yeah handsome
Midwestern type woman who was just
not having it she was like one she could
not stand her lazy drunken ass husband
and was always like berating him and
belittling him about how useless he was
um he and they would like slap each
other around and [ __ ] like that call a
ballbreaker
that Gandhi she was kind of like bottle
breaks like in a way like I don't
condone that kind of behavior but in the
sense that she was always kind of going
on about her husband about being a
drunken bomb he was a drunken bum so but
she married him um she married him
because now he was like kind of a big
dude - he was like a big tall kind of
broad shouldered kind of fella so he
wasn't like a wimp or anything like that
but she thought I guess she thought that
he would be something and then he didn't
turn out to be something he just kind of
like laid around on the couch and drank
all the time yeah so she yeah um I don't
know if he did but she ended up actually
being the breadwinner later on this was
in the early 1900s so this was unusual
like for women - maybe not in the
Midwest but you know kind of farmer
taken country she owned a [ __ ]
grocery store she ran a grocery store so
she did not have a patient yes so in a
way like I can see like yeah it's not
cool to like just kind of constantly
berate your partner tell them how much
they suck and everything like that but
it's like in a way I can see it some
like man get off the [ __ ] couch go
get a job you know that mean it's like
that kind of thing so you can see why
she was like that but that said she was
also really horrible she was like super
lutheran and one of those really really
evangelical everything is evil
everyone's a sinner we are just too good
for the world like everybody is a bad
influence so not a good situation
now they had this couple had a son
called Henry now this was seven years I
believe Henry was born in 1899 so this
was like seven years before Ed was born
now as I said I feel like just like
Kerry's mom this was like one of those
things whereas like she let the hood
and have sex with her because she wanted
a kid but she wanted a girl so the first
one that because she was like um I don't
I think she had kind of a dim view of
men in general so she has a son and
she's like [ __ ] man whatever so she has
him and she was kind of like acted the
same toward the son as she did toward
the husband like you know you're just a
sinner you're useless you'll never
amount to anything you're a loser or
whatever so then she wanted a girl so
she allowed her husband to impregnate
her once again and this time I agree
they allow the male to impregnate yeah
and then they bite their head but she
seems like she might have liked to you
know what I mean so then she had Edie
now the thing about Edie is that she
like kind of treated him like crap also
um I'm not I imagine she was probably
physically abusive too but it seemed
like a lot of it was emotional abuse
like these two kids it's like you know
they would never amount to anything ever
you know they were losers they were
never good enough you know there were
failures just like her husband was they
were like always disappointing to her
now the thing about ad though is that he
was very um he was an effeminate boy and
he was very shy and so his dad was not
super into that as a lot of dads or not
and this is another thing that comes up
a lot in serial killers like family
dynamics and stuff like that you kind of
get this dad that's kind of like oh
you're gay and all this other kind of
[ __ ] like you can't be sensitive you
can't be shy you can't be anything and
then you have this mother that is really
doting but also really abusive both
emotionally abusive and possibly
physically abusive as well now one thing
that the mother they lived in La Crosse
for a time because like I said the
mother owned a grocery store and ran a
grocery store but La Crosse Wisconsin
for Christ's sake
she talked about this city and this is
the early 20th century so I don't I
don't know what the population was of La
Crosse that's time but it's not like it
was some big [ __ ] it wasn't like
Sodom or anything like that but that's
how she talked about it she talked about
was like this [ __ ] den of iniquity is
just like everyone's sinners and [ __ ]
and everything like that we have to get
away from here you know what I mean yeah
so it was like that and it was probably
just like a [ __ ] small town I mean
yeah La Crosse Wisconsin in nineteen you
know early 1900s
I mean how [ __ ] I wonder what sinful
no it's like I don't know much about her
early life like I know the dad George he
was kind of messed up because I believe
I've read in a couple of sources this is
not real common like in a lot of the
sources about Ed Gein but I believe that
the dad's family had all been killed in
a flash flood like in the late 19th
century so I don't know if that
contributed to him just being like a
lazy drunk worthless whatever but I
don't really know why Agusta ended up
the way she ended that's the kind of
situation where there was no upward
mobility possible in that environment so
that dude said [ __ ] it he's just gonna
sit there drinking I'm just gonna sit
there and drink like cuz they're just
rate myself into death because I married
this old battle-ax and [ __ ] I'm not
going anywhere [ __ ] it some [ __ ] like
that
I do kind of feel like he just gave up
on this probably what that was about
yeah this whole thing about her and
lacrosse something happened how much I
bet she had a man down there and like a
boyfriend and he dumped her for another
war something bad happened and then you
know she got dumped and she she [ __ ]
condemned everybody yeah [ __ ] all of the
cross that's Sodom yeah it was just a
cracks pamphlet yeah it's like it's not
really that big like I've never been
there but it's like it even nowadays it
was probably not some big [ __ ] kind
of sour grapes things she couldn't
compete down there her refrigerator ass
yeah that's what they did say that on
last podcast and left they said all
these all these women that like hate
other women they call it a bit like a
refrigerator was she kind of was I have
a picture I found a picture of her she
definitely um yeah she was a handsome
woman as they say and you know kind of a
big square burly kind of farm woman you
know what I mean it also krazee-eyez yes
holy crap
she went down there and there was a
bunch of little skinny [ __ ] walking
around she got mad yeah she's like
something like that something like that
yeah they would they looked at it ate
those little skinny girls looked her up
and down went like that cross [ __ ] all
women forever because that was one thing
that she instilled in her two sons Henry
and Edie very early was that all women
except for her we're all [ __ ] yeah and
they were all just out to get you for
some of they were all like deceptive
they were all like before I wanted
prettier than her that's what's going on
there I do feel like this type of woman
is yes this is definitely what type of
woman she already got her [ __ ] pig
yeah I got her pigeon-holed so not
surprisingly you know from when they
were little kids she would kind of like
sit them down like in front of her chair
whatever read from the Bible and you
know the particulars of you know
passages that she had were all about
like how everyone's like gonna burn in
hell in blah-dee-blah
so she basically told them all women are
[ __ ] just stay away from them because
they'll lead you straight into hell like
well you know we can you imagine like
your mom who's supposed to like you know
love you unconditionally and everything
and you being like a tiny little child
and not knowing any different and just
having this drilled into your head like
day after day after day well it's
probably kind of situation where she
couldn't keep a man so she's gonna try
to keep her boys yeah that's what's
happening yeah true yeah so um
trolls I'm not control yeah and she
probably thought well she was the only
one that was like keeping the [ __ ]
together which maybe she was cuz like I
said the husband was kind of use
I don't think he had a job or anything
or if he did it wasn't like any though
yeah now like she owned a grocery store
in La Crosse and they actually made like
a pretty comfortable living but the more
that she kind of railed against how the
city was going you know what I mean like
it was everybody was centers and bla bla
bla so she decided that she was gonna
move the entire family out to the middle
of butt-fuck nowhere where they could
kind of be away from all of this
morality lacrosse Wisconsin in the early
1900s this I'm sure it was I'm sure it
was just identified issues you know
pride parades and there was all kind of
[ __ ] there was nothing like that come on
that [ __ ] by that although I'm not
saying that because I do feel like
people have a perception that you know
oh the early days of you know you li the
50s but even earlier than that oh it's
all this bad stuff we never locked our
doors above blood it's like there was
horrible [ __ ] happening back then you
guys just didn't know about it yeah cuz
I've written about a lot of those cases
in some ways it was ignorant they just
didn't know there was no social media
what kind of horrible [ __ ] had there
wasn't even really solid television no
all kind of horrible [ __ ] happen in fact
that's in some ways like the [ __ ] that
happened back that was worse and it's
like you just see you just didn't hear
about it so 1914 when Edie was how old
would he have been at that stage if he
was born in 1906 7014 I can't like
subtract at this point but you know so
they moved to what it had been about
nine right yeah so they moved to this
dinky little town called Plainfield
Wisconsin now even nowadays I don't
believe that Plainfield Wisconsin has
ever had any more than 800 people living
in it at one time so this is a tiny tiny
town and it's a house that they bought
not only was it a tiny town but the
house that they bought was like kind of
way out at the edge of town and I think
their nearest neighbor was like half a
mile or a mile away so it was kind of
like this creepy house like out you know
out away from everybody else's house
because she wanted complete isolation
she didn't want like any of these bad
influences you know coming in and
messing up her son's is how she kind of
thought they just tripping
she's definitely tripping yeah now the
kids did have to go to school
unfortunately she was not happy about it
because I guess nowadays she could
homeschool them but I guess she didn't
want to do that back then so they did
send them to school but she explicitly
told them that they weren't allowed to
make any friends they're not talking
about oh you can have any little girl
friends you couldn't have any little
male friends either you can have any
friends basically so like anytime like
one of the kids would come home and say
hey I was hanging out with so-and-so
she'd be like you can't do that you know
they're a horrible Center you're gonna
go to hell and they were scared of her
yeah as you would be because there was
no - in church at this point do we know
I don't really know like I said she was
elf style she was Lutheran so I don't
really know if it seemed like she was
one of those ones that just kind of like
sat in the house and read the Bible and
like if you didn't like listen to her
she just smacked you in the head with it
she's a lunatic what's going on like I
said she's giving me like Carey's mom
so Eddie is at school and he kind of you
know does what his mom says he doesn't
make any friends and everything like
that but um I guess that wasn't really
that much trouble for him because he was
a little bit of a weird kid um like I
said he was a little bit effeminate he
was very um shy he had kind of a
tendency to sort of like laugh or giggle
to himself like he was like thinking of
funny [ __ ] so he would just kind of kind
of sit there and he would just like
laugh and everybody thought that was
very strange so he got bullied a lot
which you know didn't help now during
this whole entire time you know Agusta
is you know obviously [ __ ] verbally
abusing them perhaps also physically
abusing them as well telling them that
you're just gonna be a [ __ ] up like your
father is and [ __ ] like that the weird
thing about it though is that even
though she was a horrible harpy
Edie adored her in a weird way I think
in later life because of the [ __ ] that
he did later I think that he had some
kind of weird dichotomous sort of
feeling about her like he hated her but
he also really loved her at the same
time what else would he have known he
didn't know it that's what I mean he
didn't know any different because they
were so isolated they had moved out to
this farm it was like a hundred and
ninety five acres something like that
like out in the middle of Plainfield
there was no one else around and other
than being allowed to go to school where
other kids just thought he was a weirdo
so they wouldn't hang out with him so he
didn't really have any friends he didn't
have any other social network any other
kind of like support or anything all he
had was his mother and he developed this
very strange relationship with her it's
like he idolized her he was just kind of
like a nonentity he was just there
though yeah for a while he died like
later but um you know when Edie was
fairly young okay but you know he was
just kind of like laying around drinking
all the time I don't know if he was even
employed to be honest with you
so he just kind of like laid around so
they had all that farmland they didn't
do anything with it though um she might
have worked on the farm the kids were
the the boys worked on the farm you said
195 it's in 195 acres I think that's
what it was yeah it was a huge model and
must have just been forests probably
most of it was damn cuz I do feel like
you don't I don't you know I don't think
it was like a hundred ninety five acres
of like a farm you know what I mean no
much puns just land like a 40 yes I mean
it's just kind of like my mom she has 10
acres but she doesn't grow [ __ ] on there
all 10 acres she just has like a little
pity garden and then the rest of its
just like you're 40 is big yeah so so
the sad thing is that it seems like you
know Edie idolizing his mom and just
hanging out with his brother he was 7
years older because he didn't have any
friends he didn't have anybody else to
hang out with
and he really looked up to his brother
as well his brothers name was Henry now
their dad died I believe just of a heart
attack in 1940 now after he died um the
two boys like wanted to help their mom
out
so they started like um doing like
handyman type jobs like for other people
neighbors or other people in town
to kind of like help her out like to
support you know the the household and
whatnot now it does seem like at this
point everybody else in town thought
they were just very good boys he's like
they were very trustworthy who they were
very reliable they were very hard
workers um you know they they did like
[ __ ] they were supposed to do and they
didn't complain about it they were
really nice um the creepy thing is that
it's in light of what he did later Eddie
was also quite well regarded as a
babysitter like a lot of people like he
seemed to like really liked children and
he really got along with them like there
was no like molestia kind of [ __ ] going
on earth he didn't seem to be like a
pedophile or anything like that he just
seemed to I guess because he was so
emotionally stunted that he related to
children more than he related to people
his own age so he seemed to enjoy the
company of children because they were
more like on his emotional level I guess
so he was known as a very good
babysitter so a lot of people use him as
a babysitter and he also did like
handyman work as his older brothers it
also so at this so Henry who is older
now he starts to realize that the
situation at home because like I said
the father is dead at this point
he starts to realize the situation at
home and the unhealthy attachment that
Edie has to their mother is not good
this is a very unhealthy situation so
Henry starts kind of clapping back
against the mom you know he's kind of
like sassing her back he's kind of like
saying you know kind of like just
calling her out about various things and
he starts talking to Ed about you know
you know the way she's raising us
it's really not right it's like all this
religious [ __ ] she does she's like you
know really abusive and maybe you should
get away from here maybe we should get
away from here so Henry did seem to
realize what the situation was and that
it was harmful and started trying to
impart that to Ed now this is not proven
or anything like that but I do kind of
feel like it's interesting the timing of
this because it does seem like in the
four years because the dad died in 1940
and then in 1944 Henry the older brother
he ended up dying in a quote unquote
accident yeah this is some odd [ __ ] here
and I'm not sure that I buy that was it
that it was an accident I got a theory
about this I do as well
okay so May 16 1944 there was a brush
fire that was burning close to their
farm that was coming close to their
house and apparently ed and Henry were
both out there fighting this particular
brush fire now later on Eddie goes to
the police and he says we were out there
fighting the brush fire and me and my
brother went off in different directions
or we got separated when we were
fighting the fire and I don't know where
he went so he's missing so the police
come out to the property the next
morning because I guess this happened
like during the night like overnight so
the police came out to the property and
interestingly they said they put the
fire out there was a fire they put the
fire out and then even though edit said
that his brother was missing he was able
to lead them directly to where Henry was
and Henry was dead now
the body significantly was not burned
there were however some mysterious
bruises on the back of Henry's head now
the cause of death that ended up on the
you know report or whatever was
asphyxiation like he like Henry had died
from smoke inhalation
but I kind of feel like maybe and killed
his brother and I think it was because
Henry was trying to get ed away from his
mother because he understood how harmful
the whole situation was and he was
correct about that think about this
asphyxiation it takes a lot of smoke to
asphyxiated a [ __ ] out of doors
all right you'd have to be right up in
it needs to be right up in that [ __ ]
fire anyone that there was no body was
not burned the body wasn't burned they
found it easily it wasn't this
asphyxiation yeah [ __ ] blunt-force
trama what it was yeah what I think
happened here we talked about this
earlier today but I think happened to
you I don't know if you agree with me or
not
I think the brother was like dude we got
to get out of here yeah mom's [ __ ]
crazy
yeah and little air was like I ain't
leaving mom because no if you don't
[ __ ] leave I'm gonna tell her what
she's been doing to us yeah okay
and Edwin [ __ ] attacked him hit him
in the back of the head was yeah law
because I feel like the weird
idolization and this is where Robert
Bloch got the idea when he was writing
psycho for the whole Norman Bates and
his mom thing this is where he got that
idea from from this particular
relationship that Ed Gein had with his
mother because it was a weird
idolization even though she was horrible
to him yeah she uh you know every day of
his young life she told him how much he
sucked and he was never gonna amount to
anything
everyone sinners you're not allowed out
friends you're not allowed to go
anywhere you're not allowed to do
anything and yet he still thought she
was like a goddess on earth yeah and I'm
not buying the holier-than-thou crap I
think those kind of people are always
yeah I think she was molesting those
boys it would not surprise me all right
it would not and [ __ ] he was gonna go
to the cops Henry Henry was and you know
Edie killed him and then protected is
not yeah and then ad runs back to his
mama and says [ __ ] he was gonna go to
the police so I killed him and she goes
set a fire out there and call the cops
and tell them that you know you lost him
in the fire and the fire and then yeah
yeah the fire burned him up but the fire
didn't get to the damn dead body yeah
because there was no where the body was
was not burned because Edie is not an
experienced guy yes he's incompetent
he's still fairly young at this yeah it
takes incompetent and the fire did not
engulf the body but he took him out
there the [ __ ] fire hadn't [ __ ]
got that far yet
ya know yeah although knowing what they
blamed his ass anyway I guess this was
1944 so it's like he was almost [ __ ] he
was 28 at this point yeah
but he's kind of like emotionally
stunted like a person who's like a 15
year old yeah and I should note too
because he was not um he wasn't like
intellectually impaired he was not
anything like that and in fact in school
he actually did pretty well like they
said especially he was really good at
reading and vocabulary and stuff like
that and when his when they did like
testing and stuff he seemed like normal
to high intelligence like a little bit
above average intelligence so he wasn't
you know he wasn't like mentally
[ __ ] or anything like that but he
didn't have a normal upbringing he
didn't have like a normal emotional
range he didn't have anything like that
I believe that the mom was molesting
both of those like I said I would that
would not shock me because that really
does seem like the kind of [ __ ] that
happens in this time you said your older
brother was gonna go tell the police try
to free his brother and his younger
brother Edie [ __ ] rejected that and
killed him went back to mama cuz cuz
he's a [ __ ] mama's boy really you
know and his mama [ __ ] told him you
know how to hide the crime yeah and it's
kind of worked yeah even well because
the police would not believe everybody
knew Liz watched it but it still yeah
well this was like a small town and like
I said everyone knew this family and
everybody knew ad is just like this
quiet
shai nice guy that baby sad and like fix
people's stuff and everything like that
no one would believe that he would
actually kill anyone though I think he
did too but it's like you can see that
no one in this time period this is like
the mid 40s no one thought this nice
gentle man would have beat his brother
these weren't kind of constrained by the
thinking of the era and yeah definitely
and it was kind of a naive time like I
said I've read about some crimes that
happened in the 40s like earlier than
the 40's and it's like there was some
[ __ ] up [ __ ] going on back then really
[ __ ] up [ __ ] so yeah good old days my
ass that [ __ ] is not good always it's
better nowadays trust me yeah I well
like I said I feel like people feel like
oh they they always want to look back to
some like Golden Age it's like when
everything was awesome it's like look
nothing was ever awesome it's like you
know what I mean people are not really
that different than how they were back
then and some of the crimes that I have
read about some of the worst ones were
from that back then but what was kind of
cool about this that time is that you
could [ __ ] up and as long as you [ __ ]
moved away and stopped what you were
doing you could [ __ ] you know I'm
talking about making a whole new light
if you start a whole new life
you could although I would argue that
from the point of view not from the
point of view of the perpetrator yeah
these crimes but from the point of view
of everyone else that has to deal with
this [ __ ] that that's not good
because it's like this dude like look at
[ __ ] HH Holmes look at how long he
got away with that [ __ ] just because he
kept moving to different states like
changing his name yeah but it depends on
who what it is you're talking about some
people deserve to die for what they did
yeah yeah I mean but other people who
maybe they deserve a couple years in
prison as long as well like I said
depending on what you did yes as long as
they stopped doing what they were doing
depends on what you did as long as they
stopped doing what they were doing then
yeah yeah cuz I'm no big difference does
it make if the dude did a year in prison
I'm a big advocate of if look if you
didn't do anything really fun
a really violent or anything and you did
your time in prison and they let you out
that should be the end of it
you did your time just let them out I
don't even think they should have like a
[ __ ] it depends on what it was
I even have and I know this might be
controversial to say I could say all
kinds of controversy well no you know
you know like the the sex offender list
and [ __ ] like that I'm in a way that's
kind of problematic because it depends
on what the person did because I know at
least one person that I know through a
friend of a friend who was on the sex
offender list and they were on there for
a very [ __ ] reason yeah um so yeah
that's got that shit's got to be cleaned
up
this is what I think I don't like I I
know I know that you have to like weigh
it against like people like whose
neighborhood isn't like yeah I don't
want some like sex offender moving next
door to me obviously nobody wants that
but you have to take into consider what
did that person do is that person a
pedophile right okay yeah that's
probably not good and I would like to be
warned about that but if he was 16 and
she was 14 right you know what I mean
because that's kind of like this friend
of a friend that's kind of what happened
and I'm like that's a different
situation I grew up during this multi
bill stuff which I think multi bills
[ __ ] if you asked me if you do a
crime and you do the time then you've
paid for that crime
and when they let you out usually they
let you out this you you paid your debt
to society because if they still think
you're a threat that you know exactly
they shouldn't let you out so really
when you think about it I think we need
to go back to the way it used to be a
long time ago there shouldn't be a
concept of a felon if you do something
wrong and you get caught you go to
prison you pay for that crime when you
cut when you've paid for that crime its
absolved you're a normal civilian like
everyone else after that if you're too
dangerous to release don't don't release
that [ __ ] don't release them
that's the way it should be
I don't believe because honestly if you
like I'm not talking
about serial killers and shuffle
obviously they should put them in prison
forever and like never let them out but
it's like if you just did like some
[ __ ] [ __ ] or you did something
when you were young and it was stupid
and you've like you know you're not like
that anymore whatever and it's been a
really long time and they let you out I
feel like the fact that this record is
following you around is making it more
likely that you're gonna reoffended oh
yeah you can't like be a normal person
you still have this record you can't get
a job you can't do this that is not
traditional to the American Way anyway
the American Way when you go back to the
17 the 1800s justice was about paying
for your crime when the crime was paid
for you were a citizen like anyone else
yeah they would just let you back out ya
know like I said there are exceptionally
the greatest lawmen of the watt of the
Old West did time yeah you know yeah the
best way to catch criminals is to have
guys that [ __ ] know it was that line I
was like okay just because the guide
committed a crime in the past doesn't
mean he'll do it in the future yeah it
does not did that that that's a [ __ ]
and sometimes it's and sometimes like I
said the the circumstances of you
getting let out and still having that
stigma falling year-round makes you
commit crimes in the future which is
because you can't have a normal life all
you gotta do is look at what's happening
in [ __ ] non-western countries like
Japan in Japan they've made it so if you
were a Yakuza
you can't even [ __ ] live a normal life
you can't even have a [ __ ] bank
account didn't I mean they've made those
[ __ ] inhuman they can't
reintegrate that's not right just cuz I
dude was a Yakuza you can't have a bank
account he can't be a human being
they're trying to basically kill him and
he hasn't committed a crime other than
he has tattoos and he's in this
organization that's what I mean it's
[ __ ] crazy
the thing though is that you I mean you
have to take it on a case-by-case basis
because there are people that are like I
said serial killers or bill that are
going to be a lifetime criminals and
there's nothing you can do you can't fix
it you
do anything about it I know there are
people like that but I do feel like the
majority of people who commit a crime
especially if they're really young and
it's like a dumbass crime like you know
they just [ __ ] like they held up a
[ __ ] liquor store or something like
that
and it you know what I mean I feel like
that type of crime I don't feel like
that should follow you around your whole
life because you're not gonna be able to
and people change people yeah they do
it's particularly when they get old
that's why I think it's good that we
have like that we make the distinction
between juvenile crime right and adult
crimes because obviously kids are dumb
okay and they do stupid [ __ ] and you
should not be judged your entire life
you're a 50 year old man you shouldn't
be being judged on [ __ ] you did when you
were [ __ ] 17 cuz everyone's an idiot
I think it's further than that I'm an
American I believe in America the way it
traditionally was if you committed a
crime you had to pay for that crime when
the crime was paid you became a citizen
after that again yeah if you wanted to
become a law enforcement officer and a
policeman you could do that yeah those
guys were valuable to the police force
which again they knew have they not [ __ ]
workers you how to catch the bank robber
in there they knew how to do other [ __ ]
they could change yeah and they've
gotten rid of that concept that a person
could change some people can some people
can like I said you have to take it on a
case-by-case thing because some people
are just terrible and they're just going
to be well but I think that's pretty
rare you got a person who's a pedophile
that's their sexual orientation they
can't be trusted around kids right I
could yeah I get that and you should
never like trust my own children but
that's very different than having a dude
who robbed a bank did seven years in
prison for robbing the bank
he goes out and he's like I'm not a bank
robber anymore I'd actually like to be
on the police force and catch bank
robbers yeah thank God guys [ __ ]
doing that with cybercrime
that yeah what they do actually what's
the [ __ ] problem he played for the
crime look at um somebody like I don't
know if you am America you just a land
of opportunity you didn't read I know
you probably didn't read um catch me if
you can about Frank Abagnale who spent
most of his teens 20s perhaps even 30s
basically being like a total fraud he's
like Chuck fraud he like pretended to be
an airplane pilot he pretended to be a
doctor they made a movie about him the
book was very good but he did some
prison time after he got out he went and
worked with the FBI like to catch other
people they were trying to do that [ __ ]
like you know how they would Forge
shacks and [ __ ] like that and I do feel
like those people have and like I said
I'm not talking about serial killers I'm
not talking about people like that that
I don't think can be helped well finally
at crimes they take their whole life to
pay off we're talking about somebody who
can pay for the crime yeah I'm talking
about generally I'm talking about
nonviolent crimes or just like well okay
no I'm gonna say you or even like Bart
you know even by bank robberies or [ __ ]
what happens if you get into a fight
with a dude and you [ __ ] judge that
study his [ __ ] ass that's a violent
crime that's different but what if he
deserved it that's what I mean and then
whatever it what if you guys were both
trying to whip each other's ass right
and so what you did [ __ ] 90 days yeah
he can't be a cop he's out there
whipping [ __ ] asses to make
arrests I just don't believe in that
[ __ ] that's what I mean is attitude
that's what I mean there's a kind of
there's a difference between a dude that
like beats a dude and like maybe the
dude dies like maybe they get in a fight
and it's like it's just like [ __ ] how to
do stairs lights by access what I mean
there's a difference between that and
somebody that's going out like stalking
innocent people that's those are two
completely different things so I feel
like they should be able to predict what
they should be treated as to complete
abilities well here's the deal if you
straight-up [ __ ] murder somebody
that's a life sentence they're never
gonna be released anyways and they
shouldn't really you don't have to
worry about that we're talking about
these guys that do this with a little
piddly [ __ ] that's one thing why do you
put them in the felon category and throw
them away forever when a lot of these
are good dudes that can actually come
back into society with them now and
maybe they'll get a regular job they'll
pay taxes it's like don't believe I
don't believe in multi bill and I don't
believe in like don't like don't give
him like further like reason to I don't
believe in the felon category if a
[ __ ] paid for his crime he's a
citizen yeah when he comes out oh yeah
if it takes 50 years to pay for that
crime then why are you worried about him
yeah he's gonna be 60 when he 80 when he
comes out so why are you where he's an
old dude we're all family comes out so
what was so the hood
we grew up under this regime this has
kind of programmed us to believe in
these concepts but when you really kind
of if when you really kind of look at
them in detail they're really not much
there what was it like that honestly I
feel like a lot of people that are in
prison are imprisoned for I'm not saying
what they did was good or it was right
or an explanation but it's most of it's
like little [ __ ] yeah like I said most
of the people that aren't in prison it's
not like [ __ ] Ted Bundy level kind of
like a psychopath that's just like going
around [ __ ] murdering people if you
know like that and if you got it I'm not
saying I'm not saying you can't keep
track of who's who like let's say guys
trying to be join the police force and
you look at him he's got 15 arrests ok
Beasley that's a red 50 correct
50 15 arrests you know and about 7
convictions for [ __ ] you know a bunch
of little weed and [ __ ] the assaults
and a bunch of little things you may not
want to hire that dude as a cop because
it's habitual its habitual right you
know I mean so I'm just saying that a
lot of the [ __ ] that we are but with it
we grew up with that we take for granted
is false and I should point out also
that a lot of serial killers and messed
up
individuals that we talk about on this
show when they get caught they don't
have any prior arrests wrong way yeah so
a lot of these people are flying under
the radar yes so a lot of the people
that you think are bad people
oh they robbed a bank a long time ago
they did this out in the other those are
not the people that you have to worry
about ultimately yeah a lot of the ones
you worry about flying at the radar for
a long time look at and gain for
Christ's sake nobody thought that he was
up to anything weird and look what this
[ __ ] was doing all this time
right you know I'm saying
same with BTK he got away with the [ __ ]
for like [ __ ] what 30 years he was a
dog catcher wannabe cop yeah they
trusted that dude he was he was a [ __ ]
killer and nobody suspected anything he
never got arrested he never did anything
like that I would I I would honestly
rather hang out with somebody that
robbed a bank 30 years ago yeah then
somebody that's like super sanctimonious
and yeah they came off like BTK right
cuz that is a red flag right there like
I said that's a serial killer yeah just
saying so alright get him back to Ed
Gein like I said now Ed Gein even though
allegedly probably he killed his brother
I think the cops didn't think because he
was such a nice man ed gein they didn't
think that he did it so on the on the
[ __ ] death certificate it says that
Henry died of asphyxiation maybe he did
I doubt it
so at this point since Henry is dead now
now ed and his mom live in this house
all alone and has his mom all to himself
just like some Norman Bates [ __ ] that's
why Robert Bloch got the idea from this
[ __ ] however it seems that Edie and his
mom didn't get to hang out by themselves
for as long as probably ed would have
wanted to because a little more than a
year later August ax had a series of
strokes now one thing that I heard she
had she had had a few strokes so ed was
like kind of taking she was still a
little bit mobile but she needed
somebody
so ed was kind of like taking care of
her now what I heard was that she's
still kind of like walking around she'd
had a couple strokes but she was still
you know alright
apparently they go to this neighbor's
house for whatever reason and the dude
there was beating up on a dog or
something like that which I guess Edie
was kind of like upset about that but
Augusta got upset because this guy had
been banging a woman who wasn't his wife
which of course that's not her business
and her well obviously well we normal
people know that right but in her mind
that was like the worst of the worst
because [ __ ] busybodies man I don't
understand like why you want to stick
your nose in other people's business but
that was kind of a ghost his whole thing
so apparently she got really upset not
so much about this dude like hurting and
killing a dog which is obviously the
more the bigger issue here but because
these two were shacking up and they were
not married so that upset her to such an
extent that some sources have said that
this might have contributed to the
stroke that finally led to her death
because she just [ __ ] stroked out
about how upset she was about how they
were living in sin and blah blah so
Augusta died in 1945 August of 1945
leaving Edie all alone in this big
[ __ ] house in the middle of nowhere
with no friends no family no nothing so
one of the first things that he does
after she dies is I mean it's a fairly
big house I have like a picture of it so
the whole second floor like where her
room was and everything I guess he like
closed it all off and like left it the
same way that it was when she died like
so he could preserve it and then he went
like full [ __ ] hoarder and he just
like closes off the whole house except
for the kitchen and this one little like
kind of it wasn't really a closet but it
was like the little storage room off of
the closet he moved his bed in there and
like slept in there and he lived
in the kitchen and this little storage
room and that was it in the whole rest
of the house and it was a fairly big
house was all closed off because he
wanted to preserve it and like I said at
this stage he went like full [ __ ]
hoarder like he's just in there like
eating cans of pork and beans and
leaving the cans in the house and
there's like flies and yeah it so it
gets a lot worse though and so we will
get into that when we come back from the
break but we need to take a break now
because it's been like over an hour no
we probably need to like refresh drinks
and walk around and whatnot yeah I'm
almost empty too so okay we will be back
in just a few minutes talking about
although all the horrifying details this
[ __ ] they found it ed Gein's house this
is so horrifying you guys alright so
we'll be back in just a few minutes
look you this cat this is because I'm
cleaning the bathroom and she's right
outside the bathroom and I'm using
bleach and for some reason Beijing is
addicted to bleach smell and it has the
same effect on her as catnip apparently
she was in the bathroom earlier rolling
around on the bath mat like a crazy
person
weren't you Beijing look at her oh you
love the bleach I know I'm not giving
granny though it's bad for you but she
is really look how excited she is you
love true crime
I love true crime and I've spent the
last three years compiling a series of
the most intriguing unsolved murders of
the 20th century it's called the
faceless villain and volume three is
available now featuring such fascinating
cases as the Caddy murders the carry
baby's case the Frog Boys the al-qasr
murders and the inokashira park
dismemberment incident the faithless
villain volume three is an involving
exploration of unsolved slang spanning
the years from 1980 to 1999 pick up your
copy and print or eBook formats on
Amazon or download the audiobook version
from audible.com and get ready for a
chilling journey through modern crime
history
right we're back from the break and
we're now getting down to the
nitty-gritty about what this
[ __ ] did Yeah right
during the break I remembered that I had
posted a picture on Instagram of me and
tiny Leatherface look I have a tiny
Leatherface yeah and I was like this is
a hint as once the show was about and
somebody guessed which I thought that
they would well look at it these are
really cool like I have a little tiny
leather face I also have like a little
tiny Freddy Krueger yeah though action
figure and a little tiny Jason Voorhees
yeah they move too don't they they are
they are articulated and also they have
little tiny like little environments
yeah like look Jason as little Camp
Crystal Lake there right Freddy has a
little boiler room and oh poor old
leather face he just sounds like a table
with like a vise on it or something like
that I think like you know what's weird
I think my ex-husband bought me these
which he sucked in a lot of ways but you
know what I mean oh [ __ ] bad about the
eggs he knew me yeah I have to say cuz I
was delighted by these so we're talking
about
Ed Gein now Ed Gein had idolized his
horrible horrible mother yeah and I feel
like when she died in August of 1945 it
was almost kind of like now it's kind of
like carte blanche for him to indulge
all of his worst proclivities perhaps
yeah running around naked and women's
[ __ ] suits women's skin see because
now he's all alone in this giant house
that he is mostly closed off because
he's like preserving it as a shrine to
her I guess and he's only living reason
yes
Friday the 13th could also be said to be
indirectly I don't know if you know Sean
Cunningham or anybody else that made
Friday the 13th was particularly I'm
sure everyone was aware of this why not
probably I don't know because like the
IED game case like I said Robert Bloch
when he wrote the novel he was actually
working
on the novel at the same time that the
Ed Gein case was ongoing so that's why
he added that whole Norman Bates and
like the weird thing with his mom and
all of us said that's why he added that
because he was like in the middle of
writing grew up with that [ __ ] man
[ __ ] Friday the 13th Part two was the
best one I think parties best one I go
that's the one I've seen like this I got
one two and three on blu-ray [ __ ]
three is not as good as I remembered the
3d one that [ __ ] is a mess but
I'll tell you what part two is the [ __ ]
I liked Part two part one was good too
but Jason's not in that yeah okay well
forget that maybe we should like review
that for a bit because isn't there a
Friday the 13th this month or is a next
month I got a check I don't care hahaha
he doesn't care he's he's not the one
that has to keep track of all this I
don't keep track of time but Friday the
13th part 2 there was a [ __ ] awesome
movie scared the [ __ ] out of me when I
was a kid well plus amy steel was in it
and she's rad she was also in April
Fool's Day which is another movie that
we have to [ __ ] review because I
[ __ ] love this did you ever see April
Fool's Day I think I'm pretty sure I did
yeah I still remember I saw that like a
million dollar when he goes down to the
shrine to Jason's mama
yeah she's got there's her stare sweater
up there and her [ __ ] head severed
head I feel like I feel like that's also
like and indirectly like referencing Ed
Gein so like I said even though heat
like he killed two people that they know
of possibly three maybe more than that
I'm not really sure but just the [ __ ]
up [ __ ] that he did after people died
and the [ __ ] that he did with their dead
bodies it's like kind of ensured his
place and cultural yeah so he's been
like enshrined in like our whole like
cultural milieu and it's kind of like
that's kind of messed up what do you
think about it but I do feel like
because he was the inspiration for
psycho because he was seeing for
inspiration for Leatherface I do feel
like maybe he might have indirectly been
kind of responsible for Friday the 13th
the whole like mom thing because that's
kind of like a big thing in the Friday's
there
teeth movie yeah like his mom was a
killer in the first one and then yes
spoiler alert yeah no Jason didn't kill
anybody till the second one although you
know those first two movies we watched
him recently they were good one in two
[ __ ] so those are really the only
ones that are good just wanted to are
good the other two are fun but like not
there are very simple movies they had
decent acting the [ __ ] actors never
Kevin Bacon was in that [ __ ] [ __ ] the
first one yeah yeah they were there they
there were good movies yeah I mean they
were punching above their weight if
there's the 13th in March we will review
at least one probably do you like the
first two because I feel like those two
are the only ones that are good yeah I
think that's it
I remembered like in part three yeah I
got it and saw it and I was like what do
you want to hear something messed up
well I saw that for the first seven I
saw either on VHS or in the theater and
then after I saw seven I was kind of
like yeah I think I've seen enough of
that right but I have seen like all of
them subsequently they're bad
I watched Jason X for the first time the
other day just because I'm serious
obviously it's part time it was terrible
but I had a [ __ ] blast watching that
of course I was drunk but like I I had a
lot of fun watching that I'm like Jason
and space yes please
really just one and two are good because
objectively yeah is the only but yeah I
do feel like we should probably do that
for this month or whatever month has a
thirteenth in it because I forgot to do
it last time so ed is now on his own his
beloved mother is dead and he lives in
this big old house all by himself
all isolated out of the etchants this
tiny little [ __ ] town at Wisconsin so
he's living in these two rooms in this
gigantic house one he starts becoming a
horrible hoarder just like on that TV
show there's a male tendency to become
hoarders when you're [ __ ] it is very
it's very common and I think I've
mentioned this on the show before but
it's like it's very funny because on the
TV show you would be forgiven for think
that it was much more common among women
because they do feature women as
hoarders much more but it's actually
more common among men they just hide I
guess they're just ashamed of it so my
grandfather was a hoarder because like I
so I know all about some about when the
end is near and you have [ __ ] already
experienced a bunch of loss you try to
keep everything you can which means you
go down as a junkyard and get a bunch of
[ __ ] beanie weenie cans and put that
in your house to make you feel that
you're in control of [ __ ] it's something
like it's a control issue
well it's associate it's often
associated with OCD like often people
that have OCD are also hoarders or I
don't know if I want to say that because
a lot of people that have OCD don't have
that because there's different types of
it but certain types of OCD and hoarding
are related filling your house with
other people's junk I do feel like well
the thing about port and I get this
because like I said my grandfather was a
hoarder like I get where they're coming
from and when I've seen like them
talking about it on the show they get
sentimentally attached to objects that
belong to someone that they loved or
something like that which I get that too
they also have a thing where they think
everything is useful in some way and so
I feel they feel like they can't waste
it which I get that too but you know
like everything else those two like
feelings are not bad in themselves but
like everything else that can be taken
to a ridiculous extreme which is what a
lot of hoarders down and I feel like
that's kind of what ed was doing at this
stage he gets left alone and I feel like
this was the triggering event for him
becoming the Ed Gein that we all know
and love
one of advice to you people out there if
you haven't used that [ __ ] in five years
though it the [ __ ] away yeah okay yeah I
know you feel bad you spent money on it
you know that yes you could use it one
day and stuff like that I know I feel
that too I know
and just because you spent mud down at
[ __ ] six years it doesn't mean that's
worth throw that [ __ ] well in it
particularly because I mean what my
grandfather hoarded was usually like
techno
logical things cameras computer computer
from nineteen [ __ ] something like
that just like valuable so that [ __ ]
out yeah it's like nobody wants that
yeah and it's like it's shitty it's
shitty that we waste so much stuff I get
that but just because you spent $1,000
on a Betamax back in 1978 that doesn't
mean that it's worth anything anymore
the only thing you don't throw out if
it's old as [ __ ] tools because
[ __ ] tools don't age you do use them
if you fix [ __ ] if you don't fix it
though that [ __ ] out
I threw a [ __ ] brand new [ __ ]
lawnmower away ain't throw it away you
gave it to I gave it to our lawn crew
well yeah cuz they could use it yeah
they could use it [ __ ] but you know I
mean I'm not gonna Boeing lawns anymore
cuz we have a longer than just yeah we
just well and plus we have a Housing
Association and if you don't keep your
grass to like a certain it's just like
BTK if you don't do your grass at a
certain thing they'll find you a long
Koufos so we like pay throw the hundred
dollars a month for somebody to just
come and do the [ __ ] and if you
haven't worn it and I said we don't get
in trouble
if you haven't worn it in three years
throw that [ __ ] a [ __ ] away yeah true
like I said it's hard for me to do
because I grew up poor and you gotta
like save everything because you didn't
know when you were gonna have some money
to get another one yeah but yeah so I
feel like Anne had hoarding tendencies
as well because you know it's not only
was he and we'll get into this but not
only was he like robbing graves and like
you know taking bones and stuff but he
was also like going to dumps and finding
stuff and bringing it back to the house
and not throwing anything out like he
would eat a can of pork and beans and he
would just leave the can in the fridge
he wouldn't like throw it out or put the
can out on the curb but whatever I guess
[ __ ] pile up in there yeah so he's
just like got [ __ ] cans maybe not as
bad and I don't know but remember that
episode of Hoarders where that woman was
like [ __ ] into plastic bags and like
I just had a pile of [ __ ] I like I don't
know if he was doing that right but she
had a [ __ ] pile of [ __ ]
bags a [ __ ] bag six feet high well
because her pudding didn't work and she
didn't like ever get anybody to fix it
and the enzymes ate through the damn
floor and it the floor plan before floor
[ __ ] collapse from her [ __ ] and but
her bags of [ __ ] that [ __ ] [ __ ] Jenny
and I saw that I lost I [ __ ] I was
like I got good [ __ ] I just well I
couldn't stop gagging I had to leave the
room cuz I kept going they ended up
locking her up though she was not they
couldn't keep she wasn't right well that
kind of stuff like look if you want to
keep stuff fine but it's like if you're
keeping bags of [ __ ] in your house yeah
one yeah that's crazy talk to that's
like your neighbors you're causing like
[ __ ] plagues and [ __ ] issues yeah
yeah and that is something that you
should not like inflict on others yeah a
whole series man we were watching the
hoarders it's like it's weird it's like
watchin that [ __ ] we were we did we were
like [ __ ] I was like oh I'm so itchy
oh that was a life-changing event
I feel like that's what a lot of normal
people like when they watch that just
like yeah I need a clean home a cloth
yeah kind of like well cuz like I said I
grew up like my grandfather was a
hoarder so I kind of like I I know what
it is to like live in that kind of
situation cuz I lived in his house for a
while on the second floor like he lived
on the first floor so all his stuff was
on the first floor and it was like he
had the same thing where there was just
stuff piled and there was like a path
yeah through and the the freezer was
like frozen over you had to like if you
wanted the food in there which I don't
know why do you want to eat anything in
that kitchen I ever did I just eat fast
food but like you had a like peck out
the ice and everything my family
wouldn't it wouldn't win tolerate we
just lived on the second floor which is
right no because we kept it clean up
there but like down this letter family
first like first floor and basement was
like yeah and there was like rats in
there and everything I didn't I didn't
like it not my family we're broke says
oh you're just gonna like he picks on me
for like growing up poor all the time
you're so elitist we would have thrown
that [ __ ] out of the family he
had so he had problems yeah he had
problems you know well I had nothing he
was it's weird he was a genius but then
he had he had a lot of we had nuts in
our family too but they weren't hoarders
he was though but you know it's the only
way I like to some extent I can
understand I can understand like the
thought behind a lot of it but some of
it is just not you can't choose your
relatives I don't understand like I
understand keeping things that are like
sentimental I don't understand keeping
garbage in your house no like I can't
throw away like a can that's empty
that's ridiculous ridiculous and I feel
like that's kind of what ed was doing
yeah so at this stage he's living in two
rooms he's in this house and he's eating
pork and beans and keeping the [ __ ]
cans for whatever reason he also gets
super into all of these magazines at the
time which kind of cracks me up because
this is like 40s and 50s right and
everything is like oh good old days
Golden Age blah blah blah but there was
always like really lurid magazines about
like [ __ ] crimes and like [ __ ]
headhunters and Nazi crimes and all that
kind of stuff and he was super super
into that he was into like Nazi
experimentation he was in like these
South Seas headhunters that were like
shrunken heads and all they got like he
was into like breeding about [ __ ]
19th century grave robbers he was like
really really into that so he had like
tons and tons of like books and
magazines about that kind of stuff and
he was just like reading about that [ __ ]
like all the time so and he was like
super super lonely like his mom was dad
now his brother was ahead all his whole
family was dead he didn't have any
friends so he's living this bay house by
himself just reading about shrunken
heads and Nazi atrocities and whatnot
also he had like a bunch of anatomy
books and he got like fascinated by that
as well now the weird thing about it is
that he was still like babysitting and
doing like handy mansion
this time so apparently some of the kids
that he was babysitting he like would
tell them like all this fascinating
stuff about how they make shrunken heads
and whatnot so the kids would like to
tell their parents hey little Eddie game
like told me about like to shorten it
like nobody took it seriously though
like nobody thought that I guess in the
40s and 50s they didn't really have a
conception of somebody that could have
this type of pathology they didn't seem
to have like a [ __ ] vocabulary for
someone that was into this kind of stuff
or because no one well but no one's done
anything about it back in those days
talking about shrunken heads what
probably considered be like quaint dad
about [ __ ] you know I mean [ __ ]
exotic now white races out on other
cotton
yes it was like it was far away with
something my way that's what they're
talking about yeah yeah which is
hilarious to me like I said it's it's
hilarious to me that people thought that
that was like the good old days when
nothing bad happened it's like oh that
was all kind of bad [ __ ] happening it's
just like they didn't they didn't like
have any [ __ ] context I guess we're
like talking about it or thinking about
it they again justified a lot of his
crimes because they ate children in
China remember that yeah well back in
China they're starving so they're eating
all the children so that makes whatever
I'm doing it okay yeah because once
you've tasted it you got it you know I
mean it's irresistible
dude I [ __ ] hate them once you've
tasted it's irresistible that's some
[ __ ] there I hate it when like people
when somebody does some things I don't
know that up there was starvation in
China but I don't think I don't I don't
think there's any I don't there's a very
okay there's like a very human drive to
protect children in general I feel like
people don't eat children unless it's
like a really really really really bad
situation well evidently some North
Korean defectors back in the 90s said
that there were some cannibalism on show
which I I would buy but I'm sure like I
think the children had died already
that's what I mean it might have just
been like they were eating they're
eating dead father already died because
they were really hungry which you can't
really I mean in the situation you're
starving right you can't really [ __ ] on
that it's terrible um it but you have to
think those people really would have had
to like go to like be in a really bad
situation to even consider that that's
funny man because I do feel like most
people 99.9% of people would not do that
unless they really really really had to
yeah you know I'm saying
what no I'm saying yeah so yeah he's
super into that he's telling kids about
it so apparently he's not he doesn't
really have the wherewithal to like be
ashamed of it or anything I guess he
also got super into reading the
obituaries in the paper now the reason
that he was wrecking the obituaries in
the paper it was because he would go to
the local graveyard at night and he was
looking for a particular type of woman
basically it was kind of like a woman
like his mom like kind of like a big
burly bossy kind of woman yeah who had
just died and he could like go in the
grave and you know that digging up the
body dude do various things with the
money yeah what was she supposed to be
doing do you know why he say all right
now he specifically said uh and I don't
know if people are gonna buy this or not
he specifically said he did not have sex
with the dead bodies because
quote-unquote they smelled too bad
however I feel like his whole thing was
that he wanted to be a woman he wanted
to know what it was like to be a woman
um so I feel like his whole thing yes it
was sexual but I don't know
it was like a power dynamic kind of
thing like a sexual sadist I feel like
he wanted to feel like it like what it
would be like to be literally in the
skin Oh some [ __ ] up literally inside
a woman's skin he wanted to see what it
was like to be a woman and the sad thing
about it is that since he was born in
the early 20th century I kind of feel
like he might have been maybe
transgender but because they didn't have
any vocabulary for that they didn't have
any support for that they didn't have
any concept of that maybe in the early
20th century it manifested itself in
this really twisted kind of way where he
got to a point where he was robbing
graves and taking bodies and they were
fairly fresh bodies cuz like I said he
kept he kept up with the obituaries he
would go dig up a woman that looked like
his mom he liked middle-aged women that
were kind of like you know big burly
women frigerator woman yeah he liked
that so he would dig them up and he
would like skinned them and then he like
made a woman suit out of women's skin
like heat and it like leather it had
breasts he had a box full of vaginas
yeah that he would wear he made leggings
I would have he made like pants out of
like leg skin damn and stuff so and he
would like put these clothes he would
put these clothes quote-unquote on and
like taper about in them so run around
in the moonlight outside so I feel like
his problem was not so much that as I
said I don't think he was like
psychopathic or sociopathic like
somebody like Ted Bundy or some like
that who just hated women and wanted to
like destroy them I feel like he wanted
to be them but he didn't have any way of
expressing that other than
digging them up and wearing their skin I
have a different take on it I mean like
I said had he been brought up in a more
loving household or a more normal
household he might have been able to
find other ways to express that I just
feel like this this was like a terrible
terrible situation all around
I have a different take on it I think
the mom was molesting him at his brother
it's possible sure I think he was into
it she died he missed it and I think he
was attracted to women like that yeah I
mean that's he was kind of [ __ ]
trained to be attracted to women like
his mom you know and he was going down
there he was digging it up yeah yeah
he's making suits but he's putting those
suits on nobody was doing it he was he's
masturbating his jerking off yeah I
don't know if he ever had sex with a
living woman or not I don't believe he
ever did besides his mom probably not I
think he had sex with his mom like I
said it wasn't shut it wouldn't surprise
me I think it wasn't right thing I don't
I don't know if that happened but it
wouldn't surprise me because that does
seem he was trying to become his mom see
yeah well like I said that's worth right
that's where this idea that sounds sexy
because that's all he knew right that's
all he knew yes and I'm not buying all
this heat you know he gave all these
other explanations he just didn't want
to admit to it
obviously I'm not buying that I'm not
buying that there's this much more
simpler answer to all that is that he
was [ __ ] his mom and he missed that
yeah I couldn't get her back so he's
trying to do he's trying to make some
kind of weird substitute you know I mean
but he also wanted to be the substation
yeah well you don't mean he had like a
weird I feel like he had this weird
love-hate relationship with her maybe he
watched his mom [ __ ] you know I mean
he was little maybe he had like this
voyeurism towards his mom his mom was
[ __ ] you know the mean putting on
shows for him and once she was gone he
decided to like take her place you know
what I mean to put on these [ __ ]
shows maybe they never
each other yeah what I was I was I was
listening to like last podcast on the
left and they they speculated that maybe
the mom had made the sons masturbate in
front of her yeah imagine there's some
[ __ ] like that going on because she
discouraged I mean like real sex between
like they couldn't have any normal
relationships with women and so maybe
she encouraged them to masturbate and
maybe she wanted to watch that [ __ ] and
maybe went the other way too maybe she
was masturbating in front of them that's
what I mean you know what's going on
with these types of these eventually
what happens it merged in together where
he wanted to masturbate bend bend and be
her at the same thing I enough so some
weird [ __ ] like that that yes I'm just
trying to [ __ ] you I mean trying to
I'm not into these big [ __ ] you know
the mean big fantastical explanations
and all this [ __ ] highfalutin
psychology and all that crap this [ __ ]
[ __ ] boils down to [ __ ] sex you
know I mean he was into it and his mom
was in there
and that's someone the guy can come up
well obviously he was he did have some
kind of sexual attraction yes mom
because it does seem like most of the
bodies that he dug up so women that they
know that he killed were physically very
similar to his mother's mom was the only
woman he had access to yeah he didn't
have any experience with any other woman
whether he had sex with his mom or not I
don't know but his whole sexual
orientation was [ __ ] centered around
her yeah and which that's messed up yeah
but there's also like a selfish ism in
sex and I mean you're trying to get off
so it's about you - well that all became
merged into one thing so he wanted to
[ __ ] being a woman's skin and
masturbate I guarantee he made that
[ __ ] Susan he can jerk off in it well
yeah I think that was the whole that's
what that was all about
that's what if you seemed south in the
lands where he's making a woman skin
suit that comes directly from because Ed
Gein he really did that I mean that's
out of my [ __ ] imagination you know I
mean I'm not all that [ __ ] crazy but
really you're a little bakery
yeah but that's what I think he was
doing yeah it definitely does seem like
this women why here's cut cross I'm
trying to pin their [ __ ] sideways I'm
in there going in that shift sideways
he's trying to figure it out how a
pervert like him would try to decipher
what the hell you know I mean and with
his limited information yeah limited
experience maybes an experience had
actual real rocks with a woman that's
how I know that's how I'm thinking how
that might have gone it was something
like that like his mother was kind of
like the only woman he woman that he
knew right 21 she had raised them so no
other women were acceptable so he was
totally focused on her mm-hmm and that's
that that's the way I see that going
yeah I mean oh this is pretty Internet
and they didn't really have [ __ ] you
know good television back then
what could this [ __ ] know you know in
and in a lot of ways as shitty is a lot
of [ __ ] on the Internet is I feel like
it's maybe saved a lot of people well at
least you could [ __ ] find out that
you should have sex with people you
weren't related to right
well after at least there's porn out
there and you can see that like no
matter how weird your fetishes other
people have that and it's like you can
talk to other people that got it weird
gay right right so and it's like you
don't want to kill anybody
Roman it's like other people have that
it's fine it's like you know what I mean
so I do feel like that's why I was
saying earlier that Ed Gein is kind of
one of the cases where cuz like some
people that we talk about that you know
some serial killers who talk about that
are just like [ __ ] Psychopaths and I
think they probably were born like that
or there's not much you could do about
it
Ed Gein I do feel like had he been born
at a different time had he been raised
in a different situation so he might
have turned out okay sounds like he was
more like more created than anything
else that's yeah I definitely do feel
like in that case so in that way I feel
like a modicum of sympathy for him
because he was kind of like a pathetic
figure he doesn't even the people that
he killed yes he killed people and
that's horrible but he didn't seem to
enjoy the killing of them as much as I
think on last house on our last podcast
and left they said he was more like a
product killer than a process killer he
did not enjoy killing people he didn't
torture them he didn't do anything he
just wanted to kill them like quickly so
he could use their bodies in the way
that he wanted to use them was easy to
the process he was right it's like I
said that's also horrifying but at least
the the victims didn't suffer like he
didn't get off on suffering the way that
some serial killers do so in that way I
can feel a little bit sorry for him
because he did obviously have some
mental issues and he's like really
[ __ ] [ __ ] up he had some [ __ ] up
[ __ ] going on his childhood but I mean
that doesn't excuse what he did
obviously so yeah so basically he's he's
like fascinated by women because his
mother had always taught him that all
women were [ __ ] but they also had like
this power over men you know what I mean
and that fascinated him because he
didn't know a lot about women in real
life so they were kind of like they were
almost like mythical to him I guess
because his mother was like this kind of
mythical figure women were mythical to
him
so I feel like he was kind of like
exploring that like he wanted to become
that because he was fascinated by the
power that they had so ed has been
robbing graves and he has trophies let's
call him that like around his house and
stuff now he's still like having people
over he's still like babysitting
children and whatnot and they are
noticing hey why does a cane have
[ __ ] heads hanging in his house now
he has a story for everything
he always says like oh well I had a
cousin that was like in the military and
he like brought me some shrunken heads
like release out
these or something like that like he
always had a story yeah now this is a
small town everybody knows that gain
he's a handyman he's a babysitter
everybody loves the guy he's super nice
everybody says it's funny because
[ __ ] Midwest men but they're always
kind of like oh he was kind of like
oddball he was a little peculiar but
nobody thought anything about it so it's
like the fact that he has heads in his
house it's not alarming to people
because oh well he says that his cousin
or relative or whatever in the military
just bought it from Polynesia the
shrunken head it's like you know what I
mean Suzuki culture yeah they just
thought it was neat and they didn't like
they were a little disturbed but it's
like with this a little weird but
whatever that's just said that's just
the way that it you're saying that [ __ ]
makes me want to go back to kill Bose
there's a restaurant I grew up with in
California
oh you Tommy elbows California might
reckon I might remember that man has
something best [ __ ] barbecue [ __ ]
barbecue ham
I've nobody showing me some pictures
like from back in the day elbows gone
now I feel like for a while there was
like a resurgence of Tiki culture
because I remember being in New York
City back in 2008-2009 and I went to I'm
like a bar there that was like a Tiki
themed bar and it was like but it was
like a dark like a punk rock - yeah
theme it was like really cool that was a
while - bad man how you two loved kill
bros too bad that case I probably would
have oh yeah really good really good
barbecue sauce it was kind of like
whiskey based barbecue sauce all righty
intrigue yeah it was really dark and the
restaurants super dry like that too so
you couldn't tell how dirty it was fry
and like well yeah that's always that's
always good yeah each booth had like a
[ __ ] menu a drink menu that lit it
was it was lit up you know talking about
did you have a little jukebox at your
table no you didn't have that but you
had like a lit up jukebox that how
the stuff and [ __ ] pictures the
[ __ ] drinks that you could buy
there's this great place I loved it I
loved it had everything hanging from the
ceiling [ __ ] stuffed fish stuffed
Blowfish [ __ ] you know like TGI
Fridays tried to do that oh yeah yeah
I've imagined to clean that place it'd
probably take a look at gigantic [ __ ]
crew 12:00 see now that's what I always
thought about like [ __ ] TGI Fridays
all the [ __ ] that they hang on the
ceiling like who cleans that probably
nobody so I feel like everything is just
probably covered with a thin layer like
there's like a maze there was like a
warren of little booths you know I mean
like some booths couldn't be seen but
it's almost kind of like you could go in
their restaurant and [ __ ] and get away
with it
because you just couldn't see what the
[ __ ] was going on in there the
restaurant itself was a big old [ __ ]
lighthouse had a lighthouse on top of it
holy [ __ ] when you pulled up it looked
like you were going to a lighthouse it
was [ __ ] awesome you loved it I
probably would have you loved it it was
cool even though I'm sure I probably
would have been thinking about getting
like Marissa or something while I was in
there because of all it was back in the
seventies man as a little kid my mom
wasn't even [ __ ] her friends used to
go and they had [ __ ] egg rolls egg
rolls were [ __ ] the [ __ ]
maybe that's why because like I mean I
would think that you because I grew up
in the 70s you were in the 70s
everything was [ __ ] dirty and gross
nobody like thought about [ __ ] germs
it was like normal well it wasn't dirty
per se it was well you didn't everybody
smoked they were smoking in there the
fact that you didn't know doesn't mean
that it wasn't dirty it was so the food
didn't seem to be dirty so you like
normal food is just it was dark in there
and [ __ ] glow there is all kind of
[ __ ] cool [ __ ] hang up the ceiling
did you turn a lights on it probably
look terrible that's what I mean but
when lights are off I feel like that's
probably why my immune system is good
because I grew up in the 70s and
everything was filthy it was like
something yeah the Salton Sea right yeah
everything was filthy baby what the [ __ ]
that is about so you're like immune
system had to deal with my Jeremy's it
was like holy [ __ ] look at all this crap
and they had to like deal with all this
[ __ ] incoming disease you know what I
mean that you have to like keep you from
dying
so you know I feel like that's why I
don't get flu nowadays because I grew up
we were tougher back eat and [ __ ] off
the floor also I I never did this but my
little brother I'm not saying what his
name is I have two brothers my little
brother one time we were all at the
beach cuz my mom used to my mom was the
Bayesian used to make us go I don't like
the beach cuz I don't like the Sun
obviously cuz of my pale complexion but
so we're all at the beach my little
brother who was a toddler at the time he
loved cheese balls like you know the
kind of come in the can he had won his
hand we were digging a hole in the same
I remember this to make a sand castle
he throws a cheese ball into the hole in
the sand pees on it and then picks it up
and eats it well it makes it taste
better and my mom was like Alice she was
like oh it did dip ya have to master
damn it he had already popped it in his
mouth too late he was fine though yeah
still though kids did weird [ __ ] back in
the day I mean he was like - maybe not
even two kids will eat anything off the
floor so it's like I feel like that
helps with it just let your kid eat [ __ ]
off oh hey come up what I thought I have
memories of going to kill Beau's
restaurant you [ __ ] want to come out
of this [ __ ] with your brother peeing on
a damn cheese ball he peed on a cheese
ball and then he ate it well it not only
had piano it also had sand on it and
whatever was in that hole in the sand
those little sand crabs
yeah there's used to [ __ ] try to
burrow into my legs in him when I was a
little kid yeah done [ __ ]
California's a little bitty [ __ ]
saying good look at a little sand roach
yeah we had yeah we had those we had
those we had like the little crabs that
would come out like every now and then
if you were at the beach at the right
time the little like white crabs would
come out of the holes they're about like
yay big if you can see like if you're
watching the video and they would come
out with their one big claw and they
would like yeah do they're a little
Claudia like they were mad yeah you know
I mean so you had that also if you went
in the ocean even if you didn't go that
deep you had like baby sharks
yeah you know go against your legs crabs
biting your toes
[ __ ] like when I was a little kid my
take me to the beach we went to this
place it was called palace of her days
yeah I've heard of that California and
they would [ __ ] jump off the damn
cliff with with hang gliders yeah lie
around on hang gliders and I was up
there watching one time dude [ __ ]
jumped off the [ __ ] cliff and went on
the hang glider and the [ __ ] wind got
him [ __ ] him all up and blew him right
back in the Clifton killed his ass when
I saw that yeah told me that yeah I was
about five I think was a big deal
[ __ ] just that guys boom air hisses
oh my god and then he [ __ ] fell hey
he fell all the way down there to kill
it well when you're five you're York I
don't give a [ __ ] oh well that I didn't
actually see it happen I saw him jump
off and then I saw the [ __ ] wind and
the [ __ ] and everybody and then him
coming back towards the cliff but then
he went out of my vision and he hit the
base of the cliff and everybody's why
and then he evidently fell down to the
bottom and it killed him fell a couple
on her feet
yeah I guess so yeah I didn't really
think about about it though my dad
wanted to buy a hang glider
I think that was the date he changed his
mind about buying it buddies [ __ ] now
I remember I want to do that now I
remember talking much about it after
that but we used to go there all the
time yeah what do you think about like
smacking into like some [ __ ] stones
or like yeah doesn't sound so fun
anymore does it
yeah it makes you want to do it though I
want to [ __ ] an ultra-light I'll fly
that [ __ ] I'll [ __ ] take it up I'll
run it down this runway on this back
path this back [ __ ] you know cuz we
have a runway right here by behind the
house yeah yeah we're right we are our
house is like right by the seminal
Wekiva
walking trail yeah in a biking trail
yeah it's like right all right it's
right on the other side of the back
fence of our house yeah I don't know
like do you really want to do that
though what's that I really want to get
like smushed up on like some rocks or
some [ __ ] no I would just get a [ __ ]
little ultralight aircraft you know it's
like a hang glider over the moat you're
really gonna get smushed up on some
rocks ish
I wouldn't do it that way though I'd
fight like I'd ride motorcycles I fight
like a ride
not scared of flying was in a damn
helicopter the door so but you have a
will I'm pretty I'm calm confident that
I compliant is not very confident I'm
confident and I'm not no I'm very
confident I can fly a fixed-wing
aircraft very confident I wouldn't fly
it that high that's that's one of the
things in a mad well the problem is that
people like so the land is not really it
doesn't account for all of the
contingencies and the environment I
would study for all the contingencies
that's not like I'm gonna jump in the
[ __ ] right now yeah I mean I
would want to know everything about it
how to recover from a stall [ __ ] how
to recover from certain [ __ ] spins
are you going to write a will though
yeah I don't have anything you could
have anyway what is it that I have it
you need we don't own the house you know
I don't know anything I wouldn't [ __ ]
you yeah I own my car you would give it
one everything that I have and what you
know because no one won't contest it
it's not like I own an empire you know I
know I own my car that's no contest what
I have my car
and all with my stuff but yeah so right
so all of these people are coming to Ed
Gein's house and seeing
heads yeah
that's some weird [ __ ] and not thinking
anything but this is what okay
nowadays if you go to someone's house
and just protip you're on a date with
someone and he's got some heads and he
has some heads in the house yeah um
maybe call the cops I'm generally you
know what I mean that's it I'm just
saying it's a red flag but like back
then back then you could make up a story
it might be plaus yeah like back then he
was just kind of like oh you know
somebody brought me the shrunken heads
from like the cell
yeah or whatever so it's like everyone's
just kind of like Oh Edie he's so he's
got shocking hate such an odd oh he's so
crazy yeah like no authority nowadays
you would be on every watchlist and
medal and rightfully so well it's a lot
of [ __ ] we should do back then that
today would be Fred [ __ ]
I'm just saying it's like people like
don't give that child gasoline [ __ ] I
was like walking around the whole
gambling stop yeah we're gonna blow some
[ __ ] up tonight boys
I know what my brother's did that to you
yeah like they're just kind of like hey
buy some fire crisis set the woods on
fire hey go get dad's shotgun yeah
[ __ ] right used to walk around damn
[ __ ] [ __ ] 12-gauge shotgun autoloader
[ __ ] remington lemon yeah
well and when we were kids to there'd be
like hey give the kid some liquor it's
funny yeah yeah it'll fit asleep
no be Who I am fella no work we're
playing bridge in the other room what we
want the baby corn beer just give them
something any green springs why go
settle down ah why did we not become
serial killers I don't know we had we
had a cool upbringing we did yeah it's
in a lot of ways well like I said my we
had a lot of [ __ ] up [ __ ] in the
seventies age you could kind of like get
away with a lot of stuff yeah but my
parents were also like I knew that my
parents like love to me and like look
after me like they weren't like ignoring
or abusing right yeah like that hey you
want to hit off this joint yeah okay my
parents never do that but you know my
parents were actually on my aunts and
drinkers yeah but they were only a
couple years older than me I feel like
that might that might be better though
for kids it's like look chill the [ __ ]
out yeah you're like well but you gotta
[ __ ] 16 17 year old Anson I'm not
averse to like giving kids pot or like a
little bit of alcohol just like just
calm down if they're having like a
tantrum or something yeah just calm down
took off of this yeah alien yeah just
chill
fine everything's fine my baby said it
was [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I can print
those lay it okay I showed her teeth
well when she was only a couple years
older than you yeah yeah she did a bit
so yeah so people are coming over to his
house and seeing [ __ ] heads shrunken
heads and he's got an excuse so
everyone's like okay fine now he did
have a reputation around this very small
town of being a little bit of a weirdo
but nobody thought anything else about
it now it should be noted though and I'm
not sure how relevant this is to Ed
Gein's case but it's worth mentioning
that during the 1940s and 1950s in this
area of Wisconsin there were a lot of
unexplained missing-persons cases now as
I said Ed Gein is not considered a
serial killer because he really only
confessed to killing two women maybe he
killed his brother probably maybe he
healed some other people but they can't
prove it but there were an unusual
number of people that went missing in
Wisconsin in this area around this time
period so some people have speculated
that Ed Gein might have been responsible
for this [ __ ] as well now one of these
missing people was an 8 year old girl
named Georgia Wexler who had been coming
home from school and disappeared in 1947
there was another girl named Evelyn
Hartley who was 15 and she was
babysitting and she also vanished so
there were some cars like some [ __ ] he
had a guy like them that's what I mean
so I do feel like maybe there were more
victims than you know we know of I
thought so too because that's about his
level yeah yeah now one disappearance
that they're pretty sure that he was
responsible for happened in 1954 in the
winter
now this was a tavern keeper in
Plainfield by the name of Mary Hogan
now she mysteriously disappeared from
the tavern that she owned in the winter
of 1954 they found blood on the tavern
floor but they couldn't find her for
many years afterwards yeah and this is
the main one he went down one of the
ones well this wasn't it but the you
know this one was actually went on he
got away with this for many years
because she'd been missing yes he did
now on the floor of the tavern they
found blood they also found empty shell
casing but they didn't know what had
happened to her for many years later now
the crime that ed Egan got in trouble
for was the disappearance of another
woman whose name was Bernice worden now
she was a middle-aged woman kind of um
according to other towns folk someone
somewhat like his mother like a very
like a middle-aged woman like kind of a
big burly woman someone who was kind of
like you know like kind of a wisecrack
and she swore like a sailor type of
woman she owned a hardware store in town
now Ed Gein had apparently been scoping
this place out for a day or two
beforehand because the day before she
disappeared Ed Gein had gone in there
like asking about some antifreeze and
about some other stuff and then the day
after that
apparently he goes in there and he's
asking about when the sun's gonna be
gone because she had it like a grown son
now the day that she disappeared was the
first day of hunting season in Wisconsin
which apparently was like particularly
in this town was like kind of a big deal
because all the men in the town would go
out hunting so he was kind of like
asking a bunch of questions about how
like where like was he going out hunting
how long would he be gone would she be
in the store by herself for how many
hours it's
so he was kind of like not in that
obvious away but in a way that in
hindsight seemed like he was like casing
the joint to see you know what I mean
like he'd kind of been hanging around
this [ __ ] hardware store and like I
said this is dumb because everybody knew
him it was a tiny [ __ ] town
so he so Bernice worden disappears on
the first day of hunting season the son
reports it they the police go in to the
hardware store they find blood on the
floor of the hardware store which seems
to be it appears as though someone has
dragged someone out the back of the
hardware store out until like the snow
or whatever so they find that they also
found a receipt that was left on the
counter because back in those days they
used to like handwrite receipts right so
they found a handwritten receipt for
antifreeze and it had ed Gein's name on
it apparently what had happened was that
Ed Gein had not only come into the store
saying that he was looking for any fries
but he also said oh I'm gonna be selling
one of my shotguns and he was kind of
like interested in shotguns so when he
came in on the day that he was going to
kill Bernice worden he wanted her to
show him some shotguns but he brought
like a shotgun shell or a couple of them
in his pocket so what he did was that he
you know they knew each other so he was
like talking to her about hey I want to
look at this gun I'm gonna sell this one
and I'm gonna buy a new one or whatever
and she was showing him some new ones in
the store so while her back was turned
she was like looking at the window out
the window it's something else he loaded
the gun that he that she gave him and
shot her in the back of the head and
then dragged her [ __ ] body out of the
store and put it in either his truck or
her truck and drove it back to his
[ __ ] Park
so and the fact that no one had seen him
do this it was because he had calculated
that it was the first day of hunting
season all the men would be out of town
they would be out in the woods hunting
so he figured he could probably do it
because there wouldn't be that many
people around so that's kind of what he
did and like I said this wasn't so much
a case of I feel like he'd been I don't
know if stalking is the right word but I
feel like he had some kind of attraction
to Bernice worden because she reminded
him of his mother she was a similar
build she was a similar personality type
she was kind of like a tough no-nonsense
like a big burly kind of woman
middle-aged pretty much same kind of age
or maybe a little bit younger than his
mom had been when she died so I feel
like that was kind of like his sexual
fixation he wasn't stalking her per se
but he knew she was right like I said
this is a small town yeah and I do kind
of feel like you have a stalker person
yeah and he didn't I'm not saying this
makes it any better but he didn't
necessarily want to make her suffer
he just wanted her monitor body yeah so
when her back was turned he just shot
her in the back of the head and just
took her body so she didn't know what
happened to her at least you took her
back home now the fucked-up thing about
this was that
so Bernice Worden's something like son
came back to the shop like later on that
day and saw the blood on the floor and
obviously became very alarmed called the
police the police came and he said look
the last person that was in here
according to this you know and he had
seen Ed Gein like kind of lurking around
the day before asking about a freeze and
he also saw that the last person that
had been in the store was at gain
because of the receipt that was left on
the counter so the police went to Ed
Gein's house to investigate the
disappearance
this is like a [ __ ] life-changing
event for these cops - yeah oh these
chops can you imagine this is the
[ __ ] yeah what is this the [ __ ]
1957 yeah this is the 4257 okay
Plainfield Illinois or Plainfield
Wisconsin rather he's this [ __ ] small
town cops they have never seen anything
they have never imagined anything like
this right this is like walking into a
[ __ ] Mike even a person that had grown
up and like the [ __ ] worst ghetto
ever this [ __ ] like that this would be a
whole other level this is like walking
into a [ __ ] horror movie seriously
because what they do they they go to the
property and like I said everybody knows
again at this stage he's a small it's a
small town guy so they go to his
property they can't get in the actual
house at the time he's not home they'd
have a warrant so they go into either
the barn of the summer kitchen I've
heard like different things because the
main house was locked they go into this
outbuilding and the cop walks in there
it's kind of dark
something brushes up against him as he's
like walking through there he like turns
on a flashlight or turned the light or
whatever it's [ __ ] okay now you have
to say this it's like at least they
didn't look for Bernice worden too long
they didn't wonder where she was because
they walk into the [ __ ] burn or
whatever this was this guy brushes up
against she's hanging from the ceiling
yeah upside down by her ankles yeah she
has been completely disemboweled her
insides it's all clean she's a you know
dressed out like a deer would be and she
has no head yeah she said banging
they're upside down headless [ __ ]
spray hanging there slit down the
[ __ ] belly all our internal pictures
that [ __ ] yeah I do and you google edema
safesearch off yeah at your own peril
cops see that [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude just flip the [ __ ] out yeah
he barf
he's never seen anything on I don't put
what this is this is a cop in a small
tent like probably the worst [ __ ] he had
a deal with it was like [ __ ]
robberies like cats in a tree or so
psychologically weren't ready for that
no they didn't know what their who would
be who would be he's got her [ __ ]
dressed up like a deer she's hanging
there yeah and the cop like it brushed
against him he didn't know what it was
cuz it was dark and then he turns a
flashlight on and it's a [ __ ] human
but like a headless body with no guts at
it like hanging upside down and it's her
yeah holy [ __ ] he's preparing the body
for whatever was you gonna do with it so
at this point obviously they're like
okay well we know where Bernice worden
went then and then they start searching
the rest of the property and that's when
the real fun [ __ ] begins because they
find you saw Texas Chainsaw Massacre
right I'm assuming most people saw Texas
Chainsaw Massacre what are you doing oh
she's tearing [ __ ] up everybody saw on
Texas Chainsaw Massacre okay like you
know when they first stumble into the
house I'm like there's all this [ __ ]
furniture like made out of bones and job
okay well that's kind of like what they
found in Ed Gein's house they go into
his house like I said it's like a
hoarder kind of [ __ ] like he's got like
all the cans and garbage like that in
there there's like flies everywhere also
he had been eating soup out of people's
skulls yeah yes go they turn into a bone
he got a bowl several and he'd been
eating out of them he had [ __ ] he had
he had a belt made of nipples nipples he
had a belt made out of women's nipples
yeah he had a [ __ ] okay later what do
you do
damn it Pookie no stop
he had like you know your window shades
on your window like you know the string
that you pull down to pull the shades up
okay like he had those but at the end of
the string was like lips
yeah like people's lips you some lips as
pull strings yeah
he had like human faces and boxes under
his bed yeah there was boxes with noses
in it
several noses I think he had a whole
bunch of [ __ ] - he had a whole box of
human vulvas yeah one of them was
spray-painted silver because it was
magic when they asked him later what he
was he was experimenting with different
methods to like preserve them yeah
and he thought spraying them with silver
paint would make them last longer well
that's what he said that's probably not
what it was I mean you can't tell me
these guys say it might have been some
kind of sexual fantasy thing was silver
look though you know somewhere Doc's
full of [ __ ] yeah he had a box full
of [ __ ] yeah I saw the under his bed
I saw the damn photographs of that [ __ ]
what now he admitted to wearing them he
would wear them over his own crotch yeah
because and also when they opened the
closet they found the charming and
delightful sight yeah of the
aforementioned he had made a vest of
women's skin yes we it had had boobs on
it yeah he also had leggings that he had
made of a woman's skin he had a face to
the face was smile and he had several
faces yeah faces that were smile and had
lipsticks painted on there some weird
[ __ ] he had some stuff in the damn chair
he had some humans he had a chair he had
a chair made out of human skin and also
into it he was in they found Bernice
Worden's head in a burlap sack he had
the the head was still intact and like
recognizable because as soon as they
pulled out of the back they said oh hey
that's Bernice Edie had put nails into
ears and then had like tied twine around
like he was gonna hang it up like a
[ __ ] Christmas ornament he was gonna
hang it up on the wall like a decoration
yeah who's this kids not right do not
write so many people he killed
some of them he actually just dug up
they weren't they weren't all of that
yes that's where the problem arose
because even though he admitted I mean
obviously he had killed Bernice worden
because she wasn't missing for that long
and that they found her [ __ ] dressed
out headless body in his barn and then
found her head which he looked like he
was gonna hang up like a [ __ ] macrame
planner in his [ __ ] house
they also found Mary Hodges head in yet
another bag she had been missing for
three years at this point she had been
the tavern owner that had been missing
for all that time the creepy thing about
this was that the three years that she
had been missing like I said this is a
small town so a lot of people like
talked about her being missing now if
anybody mentioned Mary Hodges
disappearance to Ed Gein he would make
jokes about it like oh she's not missing
she's down at my farm or whatever now
everyone there saw me was kidding
because the thing about Edie and if you
see like other people like you see like
newsreel and [ __ ] like that of people
that were interviewed about it at the
time which there's some up on YouTube
nobody like everybody knew him so nobody
thought that he was capable of that kind
of a [ __ ] so everyone just said oh we
just thought he was like a little weird
that's all that's like all they thought
so he made like all these jokes about
Mary Hodge it's like yeah she's at my
farm like she I don't know if he said
anything like as egregious as oh I'm
drinking soup out of her skull or
anything like that but he said some [ __ ]
like that but everyone's like huh and
you're so crazy he had he had body parts
from two people he definitely killed but
the rest um he had dug up nothing saying
it's a baby no they died of other things
yeah and that they were put in the damn
cemetery so he was a grave robber too he
just wanted a body parts yes I mean like
he seemed like he ran out of [ __ ]
women to dig up so he decided to kill
women and take their [ __ ] yeah
once you got it liked him of a certain
age and they had likes them to be like
mom yeah because that's kind of the only
experience and they have any fresh
enough to where he could deal with them
which is why he trolled the obituary
because he was looking for women of that
description that had died fairly
recently recently so he could like get
in there and yeah get this place
evidently evidently the deaf business
really wasn't [ __ ] satisfying his
[ __ ] demand for bodies and he was
going out there to decide he's gonna
kill them that's how it was saying it
doesn't matter whether or not he's a
serial killer or not a [ __ ]
serial killer because giving it enough
time he would have been one I do feel
like if they hadn't caught him they
didn't catch him he would have killed
several more he would have kept on run
with that because at this stage I mean
once he had exhausted apparently the
grave robbing aspect yeah of it and he
couldn't really like find it either
because like you said he was he was a
product killer he wanted the bodies he
didn't really so much care about killing
people or he wasn't into the process of
torturing women or making them suffer or
enjoying seeing them in pain or anything
like that
he just wanted one of those bodies the
bodies to do various things with yeah
and once he had gotten to a point where
he had exhausted his supply right he had
to gun me Oh bodies in the area he had
to go out and make his own body yeah and
that's kind of like what he started
that's what it looks like to me there
weren't enough fresh bodies so you had
to make them yeah which means
[ __ ] a serial killer I don't
care about the little fine print about
how many he killed get had you given him
a couple more years if he hadn't got
caught he would have done more continued
in the same [ __ ] it's that same kind of
guy yeah I mean like I said even though
his motivation was different right I do
feel like he would have and I find a
[ __ ] hilarious that they've based guys
like a race
[ __ ] Leatherface and all these are
the other dudes on hannibal lecter
because those were pretty intimidating
physically imposed any kind of guys you
know I mean even Hannibal Lecter was
luckily bill was based on them not so
much animal yeah true but although
Hannibal Lecter himself did some weird
[ __ ] that was kind of like that he's
more of a cannibal but Buffalo Bill you
know they definitely [ __ ] you well
yeah Buffalo Bill made a skin suit was
making a skin suit just like Ed Gein did
Ed Gein did watch it the thing is those
that Ed Gein was a little [ __ ] [ __ ]
when he was a little scrawny scrawny ass
[ __ ]
he wouldn't intimidate anybody in fact
that's why no one suspected yeah he
didn't even intimidate those women he
walked crept up on him like a coward and
shot him in the back of the damn head
although you know it should be said that
and this is um I think I mentioned this
when we were talking about Ted Bundy as
well I feel like when we were talking
about Ted Bundy remember how like all
these other dudes were like talking
about like what a great guy he was and
like he seemed to normal and like he was
just like one of the dudes and
everything but like women were like nah
he's creepy okay well the Ed Gein thing
that was the same like all the other
dudes in town were like what he's just a
normal dude he babysits they're Givi he
fixed our screen door but all the women
in town were like yeah that dudes creepy
because they're like he like stares at
us and it's like super weird and
everything so women were like on to it
but you know it there was nothing you
could like put your finger on but women
were creeped out by him all right so
anything or not
what'd they do with it well what ended
up happening so they arrested him
clearly because they found all this
[ __ ] [ __ ] in this house I mean like I
said if you saw Texas Chainsaw Massacre
right that's not far off like I didn't I
the dude was [ __ ] guilty he made
there was lampshades there was like
notebooks they do it he made [ __ ] out of
human skin and roads and it's like he
was making [ __ ]
cops that were involved in this these
dudes were [ __ ] changed forever some
of these guys what dude died like a year
or two later and his colleague said I
feel like Ed Gein killed him as well
because the stress of the case killed
him yeah this even though he didn't kill
him directly I think this might have
been the beginning where they're
starting to give these cops and
investigators [ __ ] counseling after
they're dealing with the [ __ ] they
[ __ ] me in it I would need counselling
after this like like especially now I
mean nowadays you know people are more
jaded nowadays which in some ways is bad
but in some ways it's good because you
don't like get quite as messed up
because you're like expecting everything
to be [ __ ] up in the 50s in a [ __ ]
tiny town in Wisconsin
these dudes had never dealt with
anything like this can you imagine going
into a house of someone you kind of knew
and he just seemed like a normal dude
you go into his house and there's a
[ __ ] headless woman what that was
like gutted and then like belton nipples
yeah and then like you go in the house
and there's he's drinking out of skulls
there's a nipple belt there's like
[ __ ] vulva rocks I think he had a
heart in a pan he did but he got a
reputation later of being a cannibal I'm
not sure if you like ate the people I
think he was just what he would do and
he admitted to this later was that he
wanted to feel like what it felt like to
be a woman so he made a suit out of
women's skin and a lot of it was like
tanned like leather and he would wear it
and he would like caper around like in
the yard and stuff in his tin suit yeah
the city city had leggings he handed
several vulvas that he could put on he
had face and calling me hands they call
those [ __ ] pants that's what they were
man this [ __ ] was sick dude
nowadays just get some gender
reassignment surgery get some counseling
it will be fine but it's like back in
those days they didn't have like I said
they didn't have any regulary to deal
with it so it's like he felt like he had
to go dig up but can you imagine I have
to go dig up
bodies and take their skins like make
ass [ __ ] skin suit what would possess
a person ICP in st. cloud possums write
songs about him after this [ __ ] that's
what I mean and it's like I feel like
even though he didn't kill like
obviously he didn't kill as many people
as like someone like the Green River
Killer or Ted Bundy or something like
that but what he was doing the bodies
what he was doing with the body was just
so like beyond the pale that people are
just like still fascinated in holidays
and he aspired so many killers it's like
lose my mind I don't give a [ __ ] what
they say that was necrophilia involved
with that well it was the sexual motive
to be sure it just wasn't sexual motives
who were living people Yeah right the
only reason why I'm gonna [ __ ] whatever
tolerate dead bodies around him and be
making stuff like that around is there
was some kind of a sexual element to
these dead women well he put a lot of
thought and effort into those two ladies
that you know I don't care what they say
I must say that [ __ ] was it was
yeah he was having sex with him he had
to have been it was why else would he be
doing this yeah well you know like I
said where's the motive look how hurt he
is putting into write the only digging
up the but now apparently what I heard
the only motive could be pedophilia
could be necrophilia that's the only
mother I I did hear that he tried to dig
up his mom but I guess because of some
of the like the way that people were
buried in Wisconsin at the time like
some of them were buried like just
normally like in a [ __ ] coffin under
however many feet of dirt or whatever
but some of them were buried like and
they put them like in a concrete vault
like around the coffin and apparently
his mom was buried with the concrete
vault so he couldn't get to her because
he did try to evidently she was sealed
in concrete so he couldn't get to his
mom so he had to like replace it cuz I
guarantee you he I guess if he could
have gotten to his mommy would have got
to her oh I'm
yeah and like I said I feel like Robert
Bloch knew where that was coming that's
why he wrote Norman Bates and he just
like went dug his mama up and like
[ __ ] preserved her and stuff because
I feel like that's what Ed Gein wanted
to do so what they do with his ass so he
gets into custody and at first he's just
kind of like tonight even though I
didn't do anything I don't know how the
bodies got there whatever why I do it
but after a while pretty much all they
had to give him was apple pie with
cheddar cheese on it yeah you have to
understand that this dude has been
living on his own isolated and he's been
eating pork and beans out of a can for
like ten years
James Mapp is an apple pie but she's on
it I'll tell you he will tell you
anything you want to know which is
apparently what happened because finally
he admitted that he had killed both the
women Bernice and Mary now he said that
the other ones he hadn't killed them but
he had just dug their graves up so he
did admit that I never had an apple pie
with cheese on it it's good what makes
that so special it's just like a really
good don't sound good at all I know it
doesn't but it's a good like flavor
combination it's it's one of those
things that you don't think is gonna
work it's enough to get a rat on
yourself it's that good well I don't
know about that all right I don't know
if I'd like admit to well I'm not like a
necrophile give you some more that damn
apple pie and I'll just tell you
anything yeah it's not that good I'm
just well
Ed Gein had he had different standards I
guess he had different standards and
also he was crazy
I mean you know I mean so they gave him
apple pie and cheddar cheese and he's
basically like he admitted it he's like
yeah well these two women marry Hodge
and you know Bernice worden yeah I shot
by them of the 22 in the back of the
head and I used their bodies for various
things he's like the other bodies that
you found on my property I dug out of
graves and made things out of them
furniture suits it was pretty it was fun
well that's probably what he was
thinking didn't cost you anything yeah
so
nobody so like I said nobody knows
because because they were like a slight
uptick in missing people in this area of
Wisconsin at this time some people have
speculated that Ed Gein may have killed
more people than he admitted to however
they did find like they did they were
able to like match up remains that were
found in his house with remains that
were you know missing from the graves
you know I mean so it's kind of unclear
whether he killed more people than he
said they do know that he killed two I
suspect that he also killed his brother
most people suspect that he killed his
brother as well
pretty sure although obviously he didn't
do anything with his brother because he
dude I think his brother but yes so he
did admit to wanting to be a woman
wanting to know what it felt like to
wear the skin of a woman he was
transgender and making that's what I
mean and I feel like this is another
case where had he been raised in a
different environment he might have
turned out okay yeah you know what I'm
saying because being born at the time
that he was born being transgender in
1906 that must have been because when
they like went through his stuff like
when they caught him and stuff he was
really really fascinated by um Christine
Jorgensen who was like kind of a big it
was like a big story at the time someone
who wanted to who was um you know
changing their who was doing gender
reassignment and that was kind of like
Ed Wood well it was a big story well he
was a transvestite that was yeah well
yes so that was kind of like a big story
at the time and Ed Gein was super into
that too so I feel like he was having
those feelings but he didn't know that
other people had that or he didn't know
he didn't have any like outlet yeah I
think ed gein wouldn't have had even
those feelings had he had a normal
upbringing
I think the gender confusion was put
into him by his mom it's possible it's I
mean it could because the mom was so
mess
and the fact that he had this weird
love-hate relationship that he had with
his mom you know that's something that
you have to take into consideration also
I don't think he was a transgender by
birth I don't think so I think he was
made that way through his mom gender
confusion you know possible although
it's possible that he could have been
born like that and then that exacerbated
it I mean and he did hear every [ __ ]
up mom and I bet you his mom that's what
I mean and he had like a really messed
up conception of women as a generator
also he had like this kind of like his
mom was like this perfect angel to him
but every other woman was a filthy [ __ ]
right and he felt like he was a filthy
[ __ ] so therefore he must be a woman
it's gonna be some [ __ ] like that I do
feel I mean that's why this case is so
fascinating because like some [ __ ]
are horny [ __ ] women and they're
filthy I'm kind of horny so I must be a
woman yeah that's it that's what are you
doing yeah I think so
the thing about him too is like like I
said he confessed to at least killing
two people he didn't confess to killing
his brother although we think he
probably as well and now a lot of the
body parts that they found like the
nipple belt and stuff like that um
they're pretty sure that that was from
bodies that he dug up so as I said he's
not technically a serial killer because
he was only convicted of one crime they
didn't really wanna can like do two
because they thought it would be too
expensive messed up so they just like
convicted of the one but when he went
underwent psychological analysis every
psychologist that they consulted said
[ __ ] so they basically put him in an
insane asylum he got lucky he did and he
seemed to enjoy it but like I said um I
don't feel pity for a lot of these types
of people I feel a
tiny bit of pity for Ed Gein because he
just seems like he had some really
really bad mental problems and it was
not addressed and I I don't know if it
could have turned out differently but he
definitely doesn't seem like later on
when they asked him about you know
killing the people or wearing the skins
or anything
he was basically I don't remember any of
that like I just kind of like spaced out
or whatever and in a lot of time like a
lot of times I don't believe that no I
mean in his case I kind of do because he
never gave any other indication that he
was a violent person or that he was
deceptive in any way I'm not really sure
if he was capable of deception in that
fashion during that trial they showed
him a picture of that woman hanging
upside down like a deer and he was
looking at it and they said that his
facial expressions changed like he was
looking at the most beautiful thing in
the [ __ ] world he probably don't
think of his dutiful yeah that dude was
he was [ __ ] he was talked out well
yeah he was messed up but like I said to
him all that she was sexually yes it was
but I don't like I said I don't think it
was a kind of thing where and I keep
coming back to Ted Bundy but I don't
think it was like a thing where it's had
Bundy where he knew what he was doing is
bad it was a psychopathic you know kind
of thing of like a hatred toward wound
he wanted to punish women I feel like Ed
Gein it was like mental illness I'm not
saying he couldn't help it
but I don't think he was right I don't
think he knew what I think it was doing
I think he's perverted yeah I think both
but I'm not sure that he realized
entirely that what he was doing was bad
I don't think he cared I don't think he
because look at like wait kills his
brother he didn't really try to hide it
when he killed Bernice worden he didn't
really try to hide it like yes he like
widdle everybody was out of town but
it's like he left blood and the thing he
left the [ __ ] receipt he didn't
really seem to care
if he got caught or not I think he was a
necrophile yeah he's turned on by dead
bodies yeah he really didn't care how
they became dead yeah he was just he
made some dead he's he was fixated on
the end product unlike the dead body
that he could do something with he
didn't care about the living person no
so much I agree so he was just it was
just kind of like a means to an end you
were there you kind of look like my mom
you remind me of my mom so I'm just
gonna like shoot you in the head and see
you don't suffer but then I'm gonna do
things with your body so he's sent to
insane asylum these days well yeah
basically what ended up happening like
he got evaluated by a bunch of
psychologists they all said yeah he's
got mental problems so they send him to
an insane asylum now some people have
speculated that he might have had an
accomplice this dude named Gus who might
have lived in the house I don't know if
that's true or not because um some
people said well he was so skinny and
it's like I don't see him like digging
up all these graves and like you know
doing all this kind of stuff but I have
seen some stuff too that said yes even
though he was very kind of scrawny and
stuff he I mean he'd grown up on a farm
he'd grown up doing farm work his whole
life
no um Ed Gein so he was like stronger
than he looked but like I said some
people have speculated I don't know who
this Gus person is but that does come up
a lot that at least in his grave-robbing
days before he started murdering people
but he had had like an accomplice who
helped him like dig people up and well
there could've sure he would have told
him to give him a different story like
we're gonna dig these people up and you
have the jewelry yeah you know I mean
and maybe there was a maybe there was
that kind of grave robbery taking
watches and jewelry yeah a lot of people
did do that kind of yeah but you know ed
was after those bodies you know that
dude [ __ ] yeah yeah the [ __ ] the
only ones in the skin and stuff he was
gonna do the best
the average [ __ ] gonna go to
the club and try to get him a girlfriend
Ed's gonna get a shovel and try to dig
the girlfriend up that's what that's the
difference well yeah that was one of
those
number remember at the beginning of the
show when I said that like there were
all these like even back in the day so
don't like say this [ __ ] like nowadays
were so like terrible making all these
jokes
back then they made like some bad jokes
about the [ __ ] to one joke that went
around in the [ __ ] 50s yeah was that
like you know what something about Ed
Guiness like the New Year's party it so
I'm here to go dig up a date yeah that's
kind of like that's what you do that's
the kind of jokes they were making
there's truth in that though that's what
he was doing that's well that's kind of
why they're funny yeah but yeah yeah so
he basically so he gets sent to a
lunatic asylum now as I said Plainfield
Wisconsin it's a small [ __ ] town even
nowadays I don't even think there's 800
people living there so back in the day
you can imagine in the late 1950s this
case breaks worldwide as it would
because this is a [ __ ] up [ __ ] and
everybody like descends on this [ __ ]
small town and what ends up happening is
that they're gonna auction off the house
they're gonna auction off all this stuff
like it's this big like media circus
now mysteriously before the house can be
auctioned off a fire starts and burns
the [ __ ] house down and everything in
it damn now they tell Ed Gein oh your
house burned down with all your stuff in
there
Ed Gein very famously said just as well
just as well yeah that's what he said
well he couldn't get it just as well
yeah now it burned that [ __ ] down well
yeah that's what everybody thinks that
they're away you want
apparently yeah because people in the
town were sick of they didn't want their
town being known for that even though it
is sorry
playing they don't want anybody prop
they didn't want any big profiting off
it I don't understand now some things
were saved from the fire including Ed
Gein's car which a dude that owned like
a carnival or something like that he
bought that [ __ ] and he toured that [ __ ]
around the country at games death car
because you know how we did a show about
like [ __ ] carnies carnies and like
circuses and stuff like that
and that's kind of like what you do you
know just like they used to do with like
[ __ ] Bonnie and Clyde's death guard
and [ __ ] like that everybody say even
though I don't think that Edie game like
Transport had any bodies in this
particular car though but it was enough
it belonged to him
so they toured it around and like made a
lot of money on that [ __ ] but yeah now
and like I said another thing that came
out of this case not only that was also
these [ __ ] sick jokes which became to
me known as gainers which kind of liked
like I said dead baby jokes but they're
all kind of like human skin like haha
we're making weapon skin suit jokes we
just [ __ ] up but like I said what what
else are you gonna do this is like so
horrific you have to like [ __ ] make
jokes about it so yeah so they put him
in an insane asylum now they did
actually he was in the asylum for quite
a while and then after he had been in
there for a while they determined that
he was competent to stand trial so they
let him stand trial for one murder like
I said they didn't want to do too
because it was too expensive they didn't
want to waste the money I guess so they
just did like the Bernice worden murder
because they had the most evidence for
that and so he got convicted of that but
then they just put him back in insane
asylum again cos he'll like yeah he's
clearly not right so they put him back
in the insane asylum and one of the and
I'm paraphrasing here but one of the
funniest things that he said was that he
really liked being in the insane asylum
but say yeah they treat me really nice
and stuff in here but the other people
in here they're crazy
hmm it's not sad that he said that he
didn't like having a [ __ ] idea
another thing is that when he's in this
[ __ ] mental asylum he's like the model
patient yeah he's totally nice everybody
that works there is like oh we wish all
the patients were like him you are yeah
he's doing his occupational therapy he's
making drugs he's all like all in a ham
radio and [ __ ] like that he's like
totally well he wasn't he wasn't
ill-behaved he was a gentleman but he
was that [ __ ] doing his [ __ ] crazy
yes [ __ ] now some of the nurses did
complain that he like looked at them
creepy right yeah which never he's a
[ __ ] bird yeah and so as I said that
was another thing we're like women like
got the vibe right I did because they're
like look at the way that dudes look a
little creepy right and they were right
about that
but yeah so he's looking for love you
guys are just a little too alive for me
looking for love not into it okay you
need to just like lay there and be like
kind of blue and like HAP Ricardo that's
my stop it's like this dude is like he
has problems so yeah so he's like all in
a ham radio and he like [ __ ] loves
the [ __ ] hospital because everybody's
nice to him also he's getting three
square meals a day
now many sorts all guys with tensions
well yeah like well and many sources
that I saw like quoted that they said
that well he gained a lot of weight
while he was in the like mental if kiss
he was actually eating real food instead
it was like eating [ __ ] pork and
beans out of a can like he did ten years
for like the dead and I'm like keeping
it so he was actually like getting real
food so as I say moved up in the world
yeah it's like he enjoyed it I suppose
so yeah so they gave him like some
medication and stuff like that so he
lived there perfectly happily yeah until
July of 1984 when he died after a long
bout with cancer so it was a happy
ending he and they buried him next to
his mom in the same cemetery that he had
robbed yeah can you imagine he died it
was safe
did somebody and the thing was it's like
for a while he had like a gravestone
like it would normally have but someone
stole edits of it so now it's like in a
museum because it kept getting a like
[ __ ] with it so as it would but yet can
you imagine I was just thinking of this
can you imagine like having a family
member like your mom or your older
sister or whatever there was like buried
in this [ __ ] cemetery that he had done
yeah and made a chair out of ya or a
bowl how would you feel about that yeah
[ __ ] games that's what I mean the
families were not happy they were also
not happy that he had gone to an insane
asylum instead of prison but I kind of
feel like that was probably the best
place for him cuz that dude was a
lunatic he was nuts and not any fault of
his own
but that's messed up and he should not
have been allowed to run around loose it
was lucky that they caught him so early
on yes it really was it's like well yeah
it's a shame that he would that he
killed two people
or maybe three probably it could have
been a lot worse though but yeah have
they not caught him and the weird thing
about it though is that he was older
like when they when he started killing
women he was in his forties or fifties
yes that is very strange so like you
said I do feel like had they not caught
him and it doesn't seem like he made a
great deal of effort to hide the crime I
mean he left the receipt there on the
counter there was blood leading out to
like the back door like somebody dragged
like it was very obvious that someone
had killed somebody like dragging them
out the back door well he didn't have he
didn't have a big knowledge of [ __ ]
you know I mean that's what I mean he
wasn't very into like you know talking a
savvy kind of guy yeah he wasn't into
like the processes like I don't want to
like kill this for like torture them or
anything like that he just wanted the
body he's not a criminal mastermind by
right and he wasn't dumb he was like
normal or like a little bit above
average intelligence but I don't think
he was thinking about
he was only thinking about the endgame
he was like really yeah he wasn't really
thinking about the process of it right
that wasn't like what the whole like you
know he wasn't getting off in the
process of it or like torturing people
or anything
he just wanted those body the body
that's that's kind of like yes cuz he
just shot them he didn't like do
anything to the body he didn't rape them
he didn't do any
like that that leads me to believe that
he was a necrophile I kind of feel like
yeah yeah and he was trying to recreate
he was trying to recreate his mom all
right is basically what he was trying to
whether he was doing it with a dead body
or whether he was you know constructing
her or embodying her by reconstructing
her with dead women that's kind of like
what he was doing and that's messed up
but he wasn't you know it's just [ __ ]
up it's like a different it's kind of a
different pathology I feel like then
some of the other serial killers I'm
talking about but I can see why this guy
became such a cultural touchstone just
because the [ __ ] that he did was so I
mean who the [ __ ] would think of that
especially like back in the 40s and 50s
would have thought of doing that kind of
[ __ ] no I said he was a man kind of out
of his time and he didn't have anything
to do with the forties of the 50s he was
just some sick [ __ ] that wanted
to have dead bodies around yeah I'm
gonna make a suit out of women you can
eat it that way it's like I feel like
you saw that in Silence of the Lambs and
everyone's like yeah fair enough
but it's like back in the [ __ ] 40s
nobody would have that would have like
blown people's minds I think it was more
but he was doing it I think it was more
simplistic than that than what they
showed in science olam said I mean dude
that was turned on by dead bodies and he
wanted to make dead bodies seek to have
them which that and bestial that's not a
weird [ __ ] but that's really all there
was to the guy I think I don't think
there's much I mean I mean like I said
I'm very like whatever people would get
turned on by I know there's like a wide
spectrum there most of the time there's
certain [ __ ] most of the time that's
fine but yeah this kind of thing he's
got a serious mess yeah yes like you're
digging up other people's family members
going through the graveyard making
making suits out of their skin dudes
just man furniture out of there
stuff what kind of dudes gonna be like
man I'm gonna give me some [ __ ] give me
that shovel it was just the [ __ ] of
[ __ ] you guys he had a box give me
some Umesh just the [ __ ]
I'm going just the vulva is right I'm
going down to the graveyard go get me
some [ __ ] I mean you know [ __ ] crazy
guy I mean although I have to say that
you know then he digs him up goes
whether to stinky what the [ __ ] were you
thinking yeah what did you think it was
you think they're dead yeah well yeah
that's what I mean it's like some serial
killers it's like yeah there's like
necrophilia aspects like Ted Bundy and
Green River Killer and stuff and it's
like but I do feel like if you're going
to dig in dead people you know that
they're dead yeah you know buried yeah
you you have to know that there's some
kind of um you know assaults that are
come gonna come out to do that dumb and
they'll earn their living in a fantasy
world they're not living in the world of
reality and their fantasy doesn't match
up with reality clearly we got a body
comes up out of the ground they're like
whoo that's not as cool as I was excited
for you people like seriously this is
kind of like you know what I mean it's
kinda like this is kind of like dudes
that watch porn and it's kind of like
that's bad enough it's like yeah that's
a fantasy that [ __ ] doesn't really
happen but it's like this is like
several levels of like you seriously
think that hold on that [ __ ] yeah your
your standard porn situation but also
the thing with porn too is that they
have to shoot it from a certain loop
like angle to make it look good and
that's no not always the angle that is
the most enjoyable for all parties
involved all right that's all I'm saying
but you know we're necrophilia fault
you have to know somewhere deep in your
mind that if you're into neck or
philia that at some point there's going
to be some um you know not that good
odors that you will have to deal with
yeah and I feel like I don't know it are
these people really that do you know
kind of like distant from reality that
they don't realize that yeah yeah this
guy was I feel like I do feel like he
Ridgeway Ridgeway liked it that bit you
go yeah you got into it some people are
into yeah yeah some people are into I
Gary where Trowbridge Way was into it we
did a show man I well it was free I
can't go on back yeah he's like well you
know might as well yeah that dude handed
in a while because I went to all the
effort to kill them right so I might as
well go back and get as much out of it
as I could
Agee and I do feel like like I said this
is one situation where I feel like I
don't know if he was entirely in
possession of all his faculties ambition
have faculties yes me I don't think he
was dumb I just don't think that he was
um entirely there no I don't know if he
realized the impact of what he was doing
I usually vanishingly Andy yeah I really
don't think like because when he got
caught like one he kind of gave up
everything for apple pie and cheddar
cheese and he didn't really seem to
think that anything was that bad about
it he was in a Slayer album yeah yeah
and you know he was just kind of like
yeah I killed him but I just needed the
body day I sorta did in my dreams
yes he's talking about it's like Slayer
album yeah man people yeah fantasy and
reality are two different things
big time and in this case really big
time [ __ ] so yeah
shut that [ __ ] down Jenny whatever suits
you guys there's no more to talk be
seriously going Etsy and they're like
[ __ ] yeah it's messed up but it's
also kind of fascinating
because they're not real I hope yeah but
yeah so I guess we're done talking about
this [ __ ] that okay there's nothing more
to be said about this dude I guess yeah
so he died in 1980 for us I got so weird
I'm talking about
Ed Gein and his skin suits so hopefully
you guys have enjoyed this rain blade
discussion on episode 186 next week
we'll be back next week remember if you
like the show like share subscribe on
all your social media Facebook Instagram
Twitter whatever it is you'd that you do
we're on all of that [ __ ] now remember
if you'd like to financially support the
show would be greatly appreciated go to
our patreon page patreon.com/lenguin
we're pres calm and there's a button in
the sidebar right there it's very big if
you would like to give a one-time
donation it goes right to my PayPal
account and goes right to our account
that we use to like buy [ __ ] for the
show pay bills whatever it is that we do
with it
and that would also be much appreciated
and I guess that will do it for episode
186 we will see you next time bye
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]